foreign
[Music]
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is Tim Ferriss for a rare in-person
podcast I know that's become the norm on
YouTube and elsewhere but this is a rare
occasion and I am thrilled to have
Andrew huberman here with me so great to
have you here in person Andrews Andrew
huberman who is this Andrew human doctor
human PhD on Twitter at huberman lab is
a neuroscientist and tenured professor
in the department of neurobiology at
Stanford University School of Medicine
he has made numerous important
contributions to the fields of brain
development brain function and
neuroplasticity work from the huberman
laboratory at Stanford medicine has been
consistently published in top journals
including nature science and cell for
those who don't know that's like having
a sweep at the Oscars but back to the
bio Andrews the host of the podcast
huberman lab which is often ranked as
one of the top five podcasts in the
world by both apple and Spotify this is
me adding a bit you've taken the charts
and the World by storm Dr hubman we're
going to talk more about that probably
but congratulations the show aims to
help viewers and listeners improve their
health with science and science-based
tools new episodes air every Monday on
YouTube and all podcast platforms you
can find all things Andrew
hubemanlab.com on YouTube that is
huberman lab Instagram pyramid lab and
also on Twitter as mentioned at huberman
lab Andrew nice to see you great to see
you so happy to be here I want to say I
grew up listening to your podcast
although I think I was in my 30s when I
started listening so for me I'm really
tickled to be here because so much of
how I ran my laboratory when I first
became a professor was based on
principles from the four hour work week
now mind you my work weeks were like 100
hour work weeks I actually lived in my
laboratory with my dog my students and
postdocs can attest to that but I
Incorporated a ton of the principles I
was following four hour body slow carb
diet I was training I had my cheat days
and on and on and on so for me
this is kind of being transported
forward and back in time nah man yeah
well I can't say enough positive things
about you and your podcast and what
you've done and as you know this is not
just because I'm sitting here in front
of you because I text you all the time
in fact I will say this I have a
notebook that dates back over a decade
where at the time I was pretty lonely
it's just me and my dog eventually
a great girlfriend at the time came
along
but I was running my lab and there's a
lot of social buffers between professors
and students understandably and
necessarily and so I was pretty lonely
and I thought like who are my friends
going to be I was in a new town I didn't
know many people and I have this list
and I read the list the other day I'll
send you a photo
and the list was of about five or six
people that I really admired and whose
principles and work I was trying to
incorporate into basically every aspect
of my life at the top of the list
there's a guy named Tim Armstrong lead
singer for rancid I've recently become
friends with
and so totally that's another Amazing
Story
Joe Strummer unfortunately I never met
the great Joe Strummer which explains my
attire he always wore a button-down
black shirt in his adulthood so I
decided to do that at some point and
much more religious your name because a
four hour work week in your podcast
which eventually came along Rick Rubin
who I've had the you know the great
blessing of having on my podcast and
learning from and then Oliver Sacks who
unfortunately passed away before
I ever had the chance to meet him but
anyway I had to tell you that that you
were already my friend before you you
knew who I was and I did that because I
would look at that list and think okay
who who do I want to try and embody in
terms of
weighs about going through life and
trying to do things right in my
professional and personal life so that
was my short list and I'm very proud of
that short list I still haven't I sent
Tim the list the other day and he was
like no way man this is freewise I'm
like you think it's wild for you imagine
how Wild this is for me so anyway to set
the context yeah well I I appreciate
that man and I've been incredibly
impressed not just with your research
and academic bona fide some what you've
accomplished there which is a lot in and
of itself and of course we've spoken
before but the incredible focus and
force with which you have
just blown the barn doors off with the
podcast which is really a service to
people so I am happy to have you here
thrilled to be spending time in person
after covid and recording remotely so we
have a ton to dive into and hopefully I
will not be the hero with Clay feet
it's all downhill from here as far as
what I can do in the conversation but I
thought we could begin with perhaps
revisiting in some respects our last
conversation not to rehash it but to
Simply ask the question since we last
spoke which was a while ago I guess it
was about maybe two years ago
what have you changed your mind on and
what have you doubled down on if you
have answers to both of those
I'll start with what I've doubled down
on
I've doubled down on the idea which
perhaps I stated last time we spoke and
perhaps not but I certainly believe that
our state of mind and body at any point
in time is strongly dictated by our
state of mind and body
in the hours and days prior to that and
on the one hand people are going to hear
that and say well duh you know if you're
sleep deprived you're going to feel like
garbage and if you're well rested you'll
feel great
that's kind of the top Contour of it but
when one looks at the Neuroscience for
instance of sleep
you start to realize that you know the
amount of rapid eye movement sleep that
you're going to get in any 90-minute
bout of sleep because your sleep is
broken up into these 90 minute segments
more or less
is strongly dictated by
the ratio of slow wave sleep AKA deep
sleep and rapid eye movement sleep that
you had in the previous 90 minute bout
and then when you start to look at the
research in terms of waking States you
start to find that your ability to be
focused say for about to work in the
morning or the afternoon or a creative
brainstorm session or
I don't know to maybe drill into some
personal issue that you're dealing with
during therapy or just on a walk or
while journaling
is not a square wave function you know
none of us should sit down and expect
ourselves to just drop into that state
much of our ability to move into that
state effectively whatever effective
means right whatever the target
or goal of that
bout as I'm calling it is is going to be
dictated by what happened in the
previous
moments and hours
and so
when I zoom out from that what I've
doubled down on is this idea that
they're just a core set of foundational
things that we have to re-up every 24
hours you know I think thanks to the
incredibly hard work of Dr Matt Walker
at Berkeley right the Sleep Diplomat on
Twitter right it's such a great name
because it's so appropriate I mean a
decade ago or so you know it was like
I'll sleep when I'm dead that was the
dominant mentality out there and yeah
sleep's great but you know getting stuff
done is more important I mean Matt has
really impressed on everybody that our
mental health our physical health and
our ability to perform is so strongly
dependent on our ability to get quality
sleep maybe not every night of our life
right I mean we have to be realistic but
that sleep is vital so a hat tip is
insufficient
so sleep is critical but sleep is just
one of about I would say five things
that really set the the buoyancy or the
foundation upon which our nervous system
is able to accomplish these transitions
that I'm talking about at all and
those five things
are sleep right in the absence of
quality sleep over two or three days
you're just gonna fall to pieces in the
presence of quality sufficient sleepover
two or three days You're Gonna function
in an amazing level
there's a gain of function and a loss of
function there it's not just if you
sleep poorly you function less well you
sleep better you function much better so
sleep I would say is at the top of the
list
nutrients
you know and there are you can think
macronutrients and so you carnivores are
only eating meat and your vegans are
only eating plants and you're
you're omnivores which is I think
probably 90 of the world is eating a
combination of those but you know
quality
nutrients I think that when I look at
all of the nutrition literature and
arguments out there it seems that
everyone can agree on one thing which is
that probably 80 percent or more of our
nutrition should come from unprocessed
or minimally processed sources minimally
processed would require some cooking but
could survive on the Shelf as opposed to
packaged Foods or highly palatable Foods
so you've got sleep nutrients but then
we should also put in micronutrients and
this is where maybe we'll get into a
discussion about supplementation I think
that there's
supplementation or supplements is a bit
of a misnomer because it implies vitamin
supplements and people say well can't
you get all that from food or that whey
protein isn't that just food wouldn't
you be better off with a chicken breast
okay well then when you talk about
convenience and you know absorption okay
but then there's this huge category of
things
ranging from the kind of esoterically
named things like ashwagandha and
shilaji and tongali and fidojia
aggressive that's right I mean exactly
all the herbal stuff right you're not
going to get that from food yeah so
should we call them supplements at all
yeah so let's just say the second thing
is nutrients and that includes
macronutrients and that includes
micronutrients as well so those two
things then the third would be
movement right and this has also been an
enormous transition in the last I think
just five years which is not just for
people interested in bodybuilding or
power lifting or for competitive
athletes but now it seems everybody
including the elderly understand that
you need a combination of cardiovascular
exercise and you need resistance
training whether or not it's with body
weight or weights or machines Etc that
you need both I mean not a week goes by
without seeing an article in one of the
major Publications out there standard
media what's called traditional media
will be nice to them traditional media
that highlight some study showing that
you know resistance training in elderly
people can offset Alzheimer's or you
know or that as our friend Peter attia
has pointed out so many times that many
of the end of life creating injuries are
due to people older people stepping down
The Eccentric movements okay so so you
need movement that's the third category
fourth I will argue and I like to think
that maybe I've helped this movement if
you want to call it that is light in
particular sunlight in the early part
and throughout the middle of the day and
trying to minimize the amount of
artificial light that you're exposed to
in the evening and late night hours most
of the time because you have to live
life just fundamental and then the last
category that's important is
social connection AKA relationships
let's just call it relationships because
that can include relationship to self um
so those things set up the core
foundation and I think one way to think
about them is just as a list another is
to think about them in terms of a of a
schedule basis and that's how I've
really doubled down is I realize that
every 24 hours I need to invest
something into each one of those things
so I think that you know 10 years ago or
five years ago or even two years ago I
used to think okay like what's the
workout split or how am I going to eat
for the next couple of months you know
what am I trying to optimize for is it
muscle is it fat loss is it just
maintaining is it energy is it Focus
that's all fine and good but sleep
nutrients exercise light
relationships those really establish the
foundation of what I consider to be all
of the elements that create our ability
to move
as seamlessly as possible between the
states that we happen to be in and the
states we desire to be in and when I
zoom out and I think about what are the
major struggles that I and it seems most
everyone deals with it's like how to get
more focused okay so we can talk about
you know what do you take what's the
supplement you know but you have to say
well how are you sleeping have you done
any exercise you really always find
yourself or I find myself taking 10
steps back and then moving through the
sequence of five things before you can
even begin to talk about whether or not
taking three or six hundred milligrams
of alpha GPC and how often to do that
and does it work and yes it works Etc
but those things really set the
foundation and so I like to think of
those five things every single day you
have to re-up on sleep every 24 hours or
try to you have to re-up on movement
every 24 hours you can go a day or so
immobile but you better move the next
day right and ideally you're moving
seven days a week doesn't necessarily
mean trained to failure and running
marathon 70s you can Goggins your life
or you cannot Goggins your life
for those who don't know I'm referring
to David Goggins there by the way who
seems to never stop moving although I
just learned meditates two hours every
night every night and I'm inclined to
believe when he says that
you need nutrients even if they come
from stored sources even if you're going
to fast you're going to fast for a day
or two okay fine I've done that I know
you've done that easy I would put
hydration under nutrients too so you can
derive nutrients from stored fat protein
Etc glycogen light you're going to need
that every 24 hours
you're going to need sunlight even if
through cloud cover
and you're going to want to avoid right
artificial lights at night not every
night but most nights of your life and
then that relationships one is the one
that maybe we can go into in a little
bit more depth at some point but
it requires focus it requires attention
every 24 hours
now that doesn't necessarily mean you
have to see friends talk to friends text
friends every 24 hours some people are
far more introverted than others but
then you're working on your relationship
to yourself
in that solo time and hopefully when
you're spending time with others as well
that has some internal repercussions so
if I've doubled down on anything it's
the understanding that there is no
so-called optimization there is no real
interest at least from me in trying to
layer in other things unless I'm paying
attention to each and every one of those
things every 24 hours you have to re-up
on each and every one of those five
things every 24 hours and if you don't
you can get by for a day or two
but pretty soon you're going to hit that
wall where you won't be able to do any
of the things that most people are
actually seeking to do and the last
thing I'll say about that is you know I
think people hear a list of those five
things they think gosh okay well that
must be nice for you Andrew and Tim you
know you wake up you look at sunlight
you guys don't have kids you know like
you don't have to worry about kids
running around you don't have to
you know you can exercise there are ways
of layering in the protocols that re-up
as I'm referring to it these five things
every 24 hours that also include other
people in your life
kids pets Etc
exercise certainly can include that as
well but I would argue that there is no
showing up properly
for yourself and for the other people in
your life unless these things are being
handled and it's not about becoming soft
and cushy it's about becoming quite
resilient and effective and I think this
for me is the
it seems so simple
but
as our friend Paul Conte said to me
recently he said you know after all the
analysis and pouring through things in
the complicated Notions of the
subconscious he's a psychiatrist after
all you know in the end really great
mental health is about simple practices
like first principles of self-care so to
which I raised my hand and said well
like what is a first principle of
self-care I'm a biologist after all and
he said aha it's basically the things
that we were just talking about
is those five things and so I I'm
doubling down I'm tripling down on those
as essential
to the point where nothing else really
happens for very long unless those five
things are tended to question of those
five let's just say if you had to pick
one that you were neglecting maybe a
strong word but under waiting that you
are now waiting differently what would
it be and
what have you done what have you added
or changed or subtracted
I'll have to pick two
let's do both end yeah the two are
movement
really change the way that I train and
exercise to some extent
and and actually my whole philosophy on
what's possible in terms of training and
how to incorporate it into a week in a
way that really works to build strength
and endurance and feel really good in
one's body all the time and then the
other one is relationships which
probably reflects my place in life you
know where I'm 47 now I've chosen to
delay having a family but that's a
primary focus but also
having done a lot of personal work you
know in toward my mid-40s you know I
thought I was quote unquote there and
then realizing that it's a trap door
it's a trap door and then realizing that
they're I guess here again I'll use
language that Paul uses which is that
there were some unresolved core
conflicts and this this idea of core
conflicts is is really I think the most
appropriate way to put the important
psychological stuff that people need to
work through everyone has them many
people have trauma not everyone has
trauma but as defined as an event that
fundamentally changes the way that your
nervous system works such that you
function less well in some or many
domains of life again I robbed that
definition from Paul conti and I'm far
less eloquent than he is in delivering
it
but realizing that there's still some
core conflicts that I needed to resolve
and I've been I've been going Whole Hog
on that and it's uh it's been
interesting to say the least so let's
start with perhaps the easier one
movement
what have you implemented what have you
embraced or cut back on in the movement
category and I'm very interested in this
personally because
I have really
taken this as one of a few of those five
to focus on myself in the last I would
say year because I've I've done a lot of
training let's just say in the last 10
years but I've not done a lot of
competition and I miss
developing athleticism
and if I take as an assumption that we
have largely evolved to move through
space to actually move and navigate
ski touring is just one example
so putting on skins these are actually
they used to be actual animal skins now
they're synthetic but you put on skins
on the bottom of skis and you
effectively Nordic Track Your Way
up the mountain with switchbacks and
then you take them off you do Transition
you ski down you rinse and repeat
but the a experience of being if you
choose your environments in a location
where you get lots of sunlight in the
morning and early afternoon
symmetrical exercise movement where
you're not too heavily waiting one side
or the other there's there are benefits
to asymmetrical types of exercise but
I have found this to just be absolutely
I don't think it's an overstatement to
say revolutionary for my physical and
mental well-being and you also get in
this particular case for me a degree of
hip extension that I really just do not
get in my day-to-day existence otherwise
so I'm I'm putting that out there just
as an example and an explanation for why
I want to dig a little bit deeper on the
movement side so what have you ended up
implementing well first of all let me
just say that your statement about
movement being so fundamental to who we
are as a species um the Nobel prize
winning
physiologist is really what he was
sharington said that you know the final
common path of the entire nervous system
is movement which I sometimes think
about
because you know we often think that our
emotions somehow uh impact the world but
they really don't except insofar as we
say things or do things right the the
other way to put this is that
evolutionary biologists will say you
know there is no fossil record for the
brain right if you look at Brains it's
only what people actually did with the
internal architecture of the brain it
all boils down to movement or Vision I
would say because I'm a vision scientist
but when you look cubic
millimeter by cubic millimeter through
the brain if you take the circuits
devoted to movement and the circuits
devoted division you've got about 75
percent of the human brain so that's
that's a lot
the rest is important too of course
movement wise okay so we did a guest
Series this was a six episode guest
series with Dr Andy Galpin who's a
professor of Kinesiology Cal State
Fullerton and his laboratory works on
does everything from muscle biopsy all
the way up to working with competitive
athletes you know so they'll do
deadlifts or boxing or whatever it is or
running
students running on treadmills huge
range of subjects and then they'll you
know stab out some muscle and a little
Cork and muscle and Dubai you've had
this done right this was in the
four-hour body yeah I did I did a muscle
biopsy
and videotaped the entire process in the
Sports Science Institute of South Africa
Yeah Tim tartar is what I called it when
it came out so good turns out my muscle
enzymes are if it's possible to be below
some type of graph representing Homer
Simpson like citrate synthase in these
various elements would be very helpful
for endurance which I seem to lack
you're built for explosiveness I'm built
for a very short duration explosiveness
which is ironic when you consider that
I'm embracing ski touring because I am
I'm not like Killian jornay or any of
these folks who would be very well built
for such a thing because I've never had
a muscle biopsy but I assure you that
when I start running distance I can
progress very fast I'm not particularly
strong I'm not particularly weak but I'm
just not particularly strong enough very
little explosiveness very little hops
which is why
you know skateboarding wasn't wasn't the
right sport for me
despite my deep desire it just didn't
happen
but in terms of what I learned from Andy
a couple of key principles fell out of
the and keep in mind these are
peer-reviewed studies from his
laboratory and many other Laboratories
of which he's an expert
and I went deep into this literature
with him for that series
concurrent training meaning getting
better at distance and getting stronger
is absolutely possible I did not think
that was possible you know I'm a big fan
of the the late Charles palquin and
others who said you know you want to
build muscle build muscle you want to
you want to be a runner be a runner and
I think at the extremes that's true but
the data really points to the fact that
you can train for many things
concurrently I took a step back from
everything I learned from Andy over the
last few years and in that series and
re-sculpted my training program so that
on any one given day I'm training for
something very specific with the
understanding that one can make progress
in a lot of different domains of fitness
in fact the way that Andy puts it I
think is better than Fitness he says you
know techniques and methods are many but
there are only a few set of core
adaptations that your body can make so
you're really just trying to create
adaptations whether or not you do with a
kettlebell or a bar or a dumbbell or a
Hammer Strength machine doesn't really
matter you're trying to create certain
adaptations by using certain loads
moving things at different speeds but
that is also true of endurance and
running so what I figured out was that
there's an optimal training schedule for
me that allows me to Target one specific
thing each day what are some of those
specific things endurance strength
hypertrophy
VO2 max
heat and cold tolerance let me talk
about why that is and also I should
mention each one of those days and I can
spell this out very very simply for you
each one of those days is also designed
to indirectly support one of the other
adaptations I'm trying to accomplish so
let me explain in short form and if you
want more detail I can give you more
detail my training week starts on Sunday
because Sunday sits left most on the on
the calendar
Sunday I make it a focused effort to
move as much as possible ideally
Outdoors
I'm thinking endurance I essentially
want to be like a mule I'm just thinking
be like a mule I actually have this
shirt that's gonna be in the headline of
this episode yeah exactly I actually
have this shirt that I sometimes like to
wear on those days it's not a black
button-down shirt but it has a picture
of a sloth and it's Crossing it's three
sloth fingers like Wolverine and that's
like what I'm trying to embody I'm
trying to embody the sloth
so what I'll do on that day is because
sometimes it's a social day with other
people in my life if I'm on my own I'll
throw on a eight or ten pound weight
vest I have these thinner ones now that
aren't these mirror vests that where you
know you don't look like you're in law
enforcement or you're trying to
pretend you're in the SEAL Teams which I
I'm not never was but they have these
thinner ones that sit a bit more flush I
forget the brand name now but I don't
have any relationship to them I'll get
it for you but I really like this one
and I'll head out for a
probably a 75 minute to a 90 minute slow
jog with some hills and I'll try nasal
breathe the whole time I'll often listen
to a podcast or a book sometimes I'll
just let my mind drift that's if I'm on
my own
if I'm with other people what I will do
is I'll fill up a backpack with a bunch
of heavy stuff usually some water in
there too and drink it as I go and I'll
do three or four or five hours of just
hiking and just trying to be outside as
much as possible
the specific goal of that day is
endurance just keep going and what I
notice is because of the other things I
do in the previous days the the 10 or 20
minutes which they come at the start
really suck like I either want to go
faster or like these little aches and
things but what's amazing is somewhere
in that 25 30 minute
period you start to feel really good you
actually start to adapt to it right then
you can go okay this is about the heart
rate I'll use this is about the
breathing rate so this is what is
happening at that point yeah
physiologically yeah or neurologically
or both yeah I'm glad you mentioned
neurologically I think physiologically
they're the standard things that happen
during exercise you're getting warmer so
joints are more fluid
your cardiovascular system is
able to fuel the relevant muscles but
not you're not shuttling too much fuel
to specific muscle groups Etc because of
course that could be stressed when I
start that I can be relaxed I could be
tired depending on how well slept the
night before
but neurologically what happens is
really important and we know this from
data what you're starting to do is
you're starting to incorporate what are
called Central pattern generators
Central pattern generators are what
allow you to engage in a repeated
movement without voluntary attention to
it very different than you know say
squatting or front squatting or doing
curls or something where you're trying
to focus on each rep fundamentally
different it's like the autopilot button
appears on your that's right steering
wheel after three minutes that's right
and at that point your mind can really
attend to other things and of course as
your body warms up you're also able to
achieve
much more output so you actually are
getting better and more efficient
as you progress now that's weird most
exercise doesn't work it is weird but as
a Intrepid
pseudo endurance athlete who's at least
really embraced this ski drawing I mean
I did I've done a lot of it in the last
six weeks
first 30 to 45 minutes are generally
terrible for everybody and then you
click into a rhythm and you feel like
you've
accessed an extra set of batteries
yeah it's neural and I think Andy would
agree it's neural you're engaging the
proper amount of what are called upper
motor you have upper motor neurons and
lower motor neurons lower motor neurons
reside in the ventral spinal cord
they're the ones that degenerate in ALS
they're the ones that fortunately most
people don't degenerate and cause
contractions of the muscle fibers they
are directed by upper motor neurons
which are the ones in your brain that
allow you to generate voluntary movement
however the upper motor neurons in the
lower motor neurons are happy to engage
in a in a central pattern generator type
circuit if you carry out something
repetitively for long enough
so as you are able to take your mind off
of the voluntary parts of the movement
it just becomes easier
and what you end up finding is that your
system becomes very very good at doing
you know for me at small steps or you
know or jogging I'm not going
excruciatingly slow but for some people
it seem really slow but that run or that
long-weighted hike
accomplishes the the endurance piece it
checks off the box of the zone 2 cardio
requirement not all of it for the week
but a lot of it and for the lay folks
out there zone two would be you could
have a conversation but you really don't
want to that's right as Peter might
describe yeah and Peter's big on doing
long Sunday rocks he throws on a
rucksack because he's tougher than me
well you're doing the same thing you're
just filling up full of water and other
I have a feeling is rucksack is heavier
than mine Peter is I've trained with
beer Peter Peter likes to push himself
so these Sunday long slow jogs or hikes
are really for my mind as much as they
are for my body
and I'm convinced that they also carry
over to my ability to endure
boring stuff during the week but also
just my ability to work longer for
longer bouts okay so that's Sunday
it also gets me outside a lot and
oftentimes on Monday because of the
constraints of the work week I'm not
going to be able to be outside as much
as I would like so you get a lot of sun
and movement on Sunday you feel pretty
terrific on Monday let's just kind of
year mark what we or go back to that
earmark earlier which is that the state
that we're in on Monday has a lot to do
with what we did on Sunday so I'm trying
to optimize for Monday in some ways too
but it's really about endurance then
Monday
is the goal for me is to train my legs
just get a leg workout on Monday first
of all I just like the way that sounds
to myself like leg workout on Monday but
it also sets up the work week really
nicely here's why I'm gonna train my
legs the way that's always worked best
for me for training which is a warm-up
and then two to three maybe four hard
sets kind of Mike mentzer darling it's
not with four straps and all of that but
what we're talking about is warming up
and then Doing Hard sets that are
heavier or more repetitions than the
last time and just so I'm clear yeah are
we talking about multiple sets of the
same exercise single sets of four
different exercises what are we talking
about we're talking about two to four
sets but usually two to three of two
exercises per muscle group I'll explain
it what that is in a moment I should
mention that the reason we're training
legs is that everyone should train legs
so the large muscle groups I'm trying to
maintain some lower body strength or
build lower body strength and
explosiveness
you know the data that I see on
longevity and just simply ability to
perform different sports and to just
feel strong throughout the body is
strongly rooted in the legs yeah so
don't Skip Leg Day legs and hips folks
exactly feed the Wolves it's kind of
funny how glutes have become the new
biceps you know like this is like what I
heard like glutes of the new biceps
growing up this was not the case you
know it was like 90s everyone was like
these like wasty you know I grew up I
went to a school of like wafey hacky
soccer dudes with like the flowy hair I
wasn't one of those all the girls like
those guys a bunch of skateboarders you
know and it was that kind of wafer uh
you know I don't know what's what it is
now it doesn't matter but train your
legs folks like having strong legs is is
great and or learn to hacky sack exactly
I'm sure that's a great skill for the
mind for other reasons the 90s the 90s
are coming back in the Box huge so yeah
you see the youngsters with Nirvana
shirts that's it's all coming around
amazing what was all this once knew
again exactly those are good years
Goodyear's bad clothes so Monday is
really about getting that leg workout
and to make my whole body strong and
what exercises so it's walk in
oftentimes I'll do calf work because
unlike you I I'm you know need work
there oh I need calf work I need calf
work that was the weak Link in the chain
for all the winter sports I've been
doing for the last six weeks yeah I I
definitely do a lot of Cav work actually
so I'll just walk through it I'm really
big on tip raises I start I warm up with
tip raises training the tip raises
meaning like the tibialis interior yeah
like dorsiflexion raising your toes
towards your knee so this is a huge
addition my program I'm a huge fan of
and Patrick and he's over toes guy as he
calls himself on Instagram
I started doing tib work about two years
ago seriously doing tip work
so tibialis raises you can do this also
leaning against a wall at an angle with
your back against the wall and your feet
out in front of you with your heels on
the ground and touching your toes to the
ground and then lifting them up for
repetitions of 25 to 30 or if you can
have a tibialis to raise machine as
they're called that's great I warm up
with tib work why
training my tips as they're called has
tips in the new biceps
definitely makes the calf work more
effective
never could grow calves or get my calves
strong gotten them you know
substantially bigger and stronger by
training tips but more importantly
perhaps helps posture got rid of my
right side sciatica I always had this
right side kind of leaning in pain and I
can forgive the I'm gonna get teased for
saying this
for me anyway I can run like a beast now
no knee pain no back pain no shoulder
pain I can just run and run and run and
so training your tips turns out to be
key and it turns out it has everything
to do with it bring your toe we'll avoid
jargon here bring your toe closer to the
kneecap as you generate your stride not
having the floppy right so if you lay
down on your night and your toes are
just kind of flopping towards the end of
the bed your tips are weak a lot of
people with knee issues have weak tips
well hold on hold on so if you're in the
bed you got your sheets and blankets on
top and your feet are flopping forward
do you are you sleeping like a GI Joe
figure with your toes pulled up to your
knees no no I just mean that if you're
if your toes are in a state of kind of
like flaccid relaxation your if your
feet are flaccid flaccid toasted not
good red light a lot of people who run
are smacking their feet against the
ground you know Ben cued people to this
tib work okay tib work is great for the
calves it's great for the knee it's
great for the hip that's all very clear
and I think just a lot of people have
over trained their calves yeah and not
bounce it out with tib work it would be
like doing a lot of bicep working on a
lot of tricep work or a lot of quad work
not a lot of hamstring works you have to
work both sides of the limb and I think
our friend Kelly Starrett would agree
I'm sure it would yeah tib work has
changed everything for me posturally I
have no pain anymore I just want a lodge
a formal complaint against Kelly
Starrett people should look him up
because he is a large man very his
Quadzilla he's 230 Maybe
former high level
competitive kayaker I think he
celebrated his 40th birthday by doing a
standing back flip running an ultra and
something else and he's a really good
skier I just want to say it really
upsets me that he has no discernible
physical weaknesses it's very irritating
I'm a nice guy yeah and a nice guy and a
nice guy yeah he's very very strong 600
pound deadlift he's he's a strong unit
it's a beast so tip work so I start with
tip raises so it's gonna be a couple
warm-ups maybe a 12 rep warm-up an eight
rep warm-up and then I'll do you know
three sets per
tib of anywhere from six to ten reps
okay
Andy Galpin told me in the literature
supports people like Brad schoenfield
and others have shown that for
hypertrophy for muscle growth
6 to 30 reps anywhere in there can get
you hypertrophy if you go to failure and
if you go hard I personally like to keep
my resistance workouts an hour or less I
like to train in the more or less the
five to ten repetition range for
strength and for hypertrophy and I'm
kind of going for a mix of both so I
train tips then I do sled or standing
calf raises same thing two to four sets
five to eight maybe ten repetitions are
these sets to failure these are sets to
failure and you know long ago I had gift
of learning from the great Mike menser
and these are sets to failure like I
can't budge another micro inch but I'm
not quaking and I'm not breaking form
I'm trying to keep everything nice and
taut and rigid because I just I can't
afford an injury at this point not
because no flaccid feet yeah I'm telling
you The Tib work is is a game changer
and knees over toes guy Ben Patrick is
the one who's been teaching people that
yes everyone can dunk most everyone can
dunk he does like dunks into back bends
and all this stuff and it largely hinges
on tip work and quality posterior chain
work like things like Nordic curls so
I'm training calves that takes about
10-15 minutes total I try and move
relatively quickly through that so two
to three minutes rest maybe four if I'm
going for heavy set then I'm weaker in
the hamstrings than I am in my quads so
I do
two warm-ups and then two to four
working sets of
lying light curls or standard stuff
lying leg curls meaning on a machine
yeah not like reverse yeah like a
nautilus machine not seated doesn't work
for me just lying like girls yep and not
the Hoist machines that move with you to
make it easier no
and maybe the occasional Force wrap if
somebody's there you know to help me
then I go do two to four sets but
typically three of glute ham raises
which is an incredible exercise the
equipment isn't in every gym but I'm
doing
you know about three you know so three
or four sets of blue ham raises going
slow and you know this is basically like
if you were going to do a dead lift
everyone knows what a deadlift is but
now take the ground and rotate it 90
degrees and make it the wall that's what
a glute Hammer is really is it allows
you to do a dead lift but then at the
top do a leg curl so if you think about
it that way like you just tilted the
ground you just rotate it
counterclockwise okay we'll get a link
to a YouTube video folks exactly blue
hand raises are great lower back so
entire posterior chain so then I'm done
with calves and hamstrings and then I'll
do two or three sets of leg extensions
so maybe a warm-up and then two or three
sets of working leg extensions which for
whatever reasons are incredibly painful
I hate them but they work to isolate the
quads and then two or three sets of
working hack squats after a warm-up hack
squats heavy heavy heavy heavy and then
I'm done I'm out Monday's done now again
going back to the kind of overall theme
the ideas hack squats specifically
versus other forms of squats yeah back
squats for me I always got like an
internal hip pain I had every squat
coach in the world tell me how to do it
better even tell me how was doing it
right and then I end up with the same
thing yeah and I don't really care if I
can squat x amount of weight no you're
not doing it for power living
competition doing it for strength and
Aesthetics you know Aesthetics just
because of some balance I'm not trying
to get huge legs but I mean I'm six one
two twenty I sit like more or less right
there all the time my body fat goes up
for now I might gain five pounds or lose
five pounds but like I'm kind of
hovering around there I don't have any
interest in being much larger or much
well I want to keep my strength maybe
build some as I get older
and so hack squats allow me to put a lot
of weight on there and keep my nice
right angle between the hip and my back
you describe for folks just in case
they're gonna go searching for this what
is the visual of a hack Squad hack squat
you're sitting back your back is against
a sled you're holding the handles up
near your ears and then you're squatting
down your feet are on a 45 degree or
ideally if you can find it a 30 degree
platform below you so it's not a leg
press it's a hack squat now for people
that don't have access to these and
unfortunately a lot of gyms don't have
them anymore
or just don't keep them around for
whatever reason
weighted [__] squats as they're
sometimes called can work where you're
holding on to a plate and you're
squatting down while holding onto a
deceptively hard to do if you do it
under control and with good technique
and if you're doing your tib work great
way to stretch your quads in ski boots
too if you're going up and yeah well
recently our our podcast team took a
little ski trip I was snowboarding and I
was
it's been a long time since I've been on
a snowboard but you start to feel how
many of these movements translate as you
point out
and I should say that the [__] squats
you know a lot of people think you can't
bring your knee out over your toe and
this is what Ben Patrick has really been
trying to impress on people look at
skateboarders
land their knees go out over their toes
yeah a foot beyond their toes look at
Olympic weight of course gymnasts
Olympic weightlifters this whole like
knee can't pass the toe thing is just
silly so you can feel very comfortable
very strong at the bottom of one of
these [__] squats or hack squats that
way and so the whole purpose of that
Monday workout is it's like the opposite
of what I'm doing on Sunday it's get
stronger maintain some size but really
get stronger in the legs and just for
people listening who are like for [__]
sake it's going to take us six hours to
get to Saturday part of the reason that
I want to dig into this day specifically
is because it's so neglected people do
not tend to exercise with a focus on
their legs right but the the the direct
and collateral benefits you're so
numerous that I want to just drill into
this when you look at the literature on
cognitive improvements from resistance
training it's not from biceps curls it's
not from bench presses I suppose it
could be from things like dips which are
sort of like a upper body squat of sorts
especially if they're weighted or with
rings or something but
training the legs is key and so as I
said before there are two goals one is
to get the legs stronger the other is
that I'm trying to create a systemic
anabolic effect on the body I was just
about to say if you want to lose body
fat also the systemic sort of endocrine
slash anabolic effect from doing this
lower body exercise it's real work it's
significant it's real work and resting
long between the sets especially the the
hamstring and quad work you know four or
five minutes so you start to feel lazy
but you're going all out you're
breathing really hard during after the
set you know sometimes you feel like
you're gonna pass out I haven't puked
from a leg workout yet which people tell
me means I haven't really trained hard
but I just say that I just don't have a
weak weak stomach like the rest of them
I mean look as as Kelly Star I would say
it's like 20 rep squats work just great
and you'll puke into a bucket but you're
not gonna be able to do much else for
the next week if you do them really
intensely yeah I mean it's gonna hurt
your ass every time you sit on a toilet
seat so you're not going to be doing a
whole lot of basketball very well yeah I
want strong legs I want a strong body I
want a body that can accomplish
endurance and I want the cognitive
effects so you get that systemic
anabolic effect there's another sort of
practical reason for doing this on
Monday which is
sometimes I might not train again until
Thursday
and if you trained your legs properly
and you you can know that you you
initiated a number of
good processes in your brain and body
made a down payment for the week you
made a bit down payment also if you
think about the neural circuits involved
in generating the kinds of movements I
just described for the Monday workout
they're fundamentally different than the
kinds of movements required for and
neural circuits required for generating
movement so the Sunday long workout
they're both legs you're running on your
legs you're walking your legs of course
but very very different different muscle
fiber types different motor neurons and
different range of motion too different
range of motion and different mindset
required and keep in mind the entire leg
workout takes
10 minutes of warm up in about 55-0
minutes of training Tuesday is very
different oh and by the way Monday is a
very heavy work day for me typically we
launch podcasts I do all my own social
media so I'm I post the assets I really
like doing that respond to comments
dealing with grants dealing with papers
dealing with so money is heavy work day
so getting the leg workout done early on
Monday is really key for me these days I
don't ever really do resistance training
past 11 A.M and ideally earlier in the
day and we won't go into whether or not
it's fasted or fed or other because
cover that I have a tool kit where I
list out some of that and how different
processes layer together and I can link
to that I would also say not to
interject but I will if people are like
but wait I can't start until I know if
it's faster non-fasted or if I should be
swinging a dead cat over my head on
Tuesday or Wednesday night it's like
just get started yeah you got plenty to
get started yeah I do it fasted but I
drink caffeine first and water and
listen I usually eat a bit more on the
weekend this is great Sunday night
you're putting in your fuel sources for
your Monday workout there are all sorts
of ways this layer cookies
it's like pizza is though I do love
pizza no cheat days anymore for me
however I haven't done one in a while
I'm actually thinking of going back on
for for our body just try it and do it
gotta still work I said cookies I'll
make a very embarrassing admission which
is I am going to be going back on to
strict slow carb okay and so I had these
incredible cookies last night we're not
going to spend a lot of time on this
because we do need to get Tuesday but it
was sort of my last hurray for locking
down the fort so yes I'm getting back
great I'm getting back let me know I'll
start I'll start with you lots of
stories about cheat days Mike's
girlfriend at least do the cheat days
together in it at one point because I'll
blame myself we were in couples therapy
and we're asking like so describe a week
for yourself and she's like well then on
Sunday we're eating like eight
croissants and then we're doing this
therapist was looking at excuse me I'm
like spitting here laughing's hard
trying not to laugh like what in the
world is this you know but we had a good
time with it she was one of these
mutants that could just eat anything
drink anything and feel fine the next
day and
yeah so the Tuesday is very different
Tuesday I don't want to call it a
recovery day but Tuesday I'm doing
something really different first of all
my legs need recovery
so what I'll do is
substantial amounts of deliberate heat
exposure and deliberate cold exposure
yes I do cold showers in the morning
first thing nowadays yes it is
a bad idea to do cold water immersion
after hypertrophy training so just for
the record you don't want to get into an
ice bath after hypertrophy training in
the six hours after a hypertrophy
training because it can blunt the
hypertrophy it blocks the inflammation
which is exactly what you want to
trigger the adaptation of hypertrophy
but Tuesday is really about getting the
maximum effect of heat exposure and cold
exposure and when I've I've done
multiple episodes on each one of those I
learned about deliberate cold exposure
from you so thank you Tim I do a
protocol which is pretty intense
designed to amplify growth hormone
stimulate a bunch of mood positive mood
promoting hormones that last not just
days but weeks say the literature and
just get better at it so I'll do 20
minutes of sauna hot sauna what is hot
man I'm up to like 260 now okay 260. but
I worked up to that you know you can
check out the Banya I'll give a plug to
these folks there's spy88 on Wall Street
in New York they are amazing they are
incredible that's they have a hot
Russian song Cherry and Archimedes Banya
in San Francisco fantastic it's great a
couple of notes about that one it's
clothing optional I wear my swim trunks
when I go how are you gonna show off
those glutes you're working so hard but
it but it is so just know what you're
getting into it's co-ed and clothing
optional and it is in Hunter's Point Bay
View which is a rough neighborhood yeah
I wouldn't go for a jog yeah don't leave
anything in your car but don't do that
anywhere in San Francisco now yeah so
20 minutes in the sauna very hot three
to five minutes in the cold plunge up to
the neck back into the sauna for 20
minutes back into the cold plunge for
three to five minutes back into the
sauna for 20 minutes back into the cold
plunge for three to five minutes it's
work
but it's amazing in the sense that you
recover very well from the leg day
you
generate all the hormone
neurotransmitter type of adaptations
that one wants and you get very very
good at tolerating heat and cold and I
should mention during these times if
there isn't someone else there I'm
listening to books I'm thinking I'm
putting this work and time to use so
there's multiple things going on there
then Wednesday
I do one of two things I'm either going
to do a shorter duration than Sunday
cardiovascular training workout so I
might do I'm thinking about five minutes
of warm up and then about 25 to 30
minutes of usually running for me where
I'm just trying to get out and cover as
much distance as I can at a fast clip
but steady so I'm not Sprint stop Sprint
stop that's typically what I'll do on
Wednesday although if my legs are still
a little bit sore that's when I'll train
and hear the bodybuilders are just going
to go oh they're going to scoff I train
what I call torso
what do I do I try to get
pushing through the chest and shoulders
I'm trying to pull for the back I
already got my lower back where the
glute ham raises so
what I tend to do is overhead shoulder
presses after a warm-up two to three
sets working sets or maybe four
I like ring dips and dips these days
those are hard for me but I you know two
or three work sets of those so your
chest shoulders and
and I'm gonna upset some people here but
I don't tend to train back every week I
do it every other week because just I
have some genetic abnormality where
those grow really easily and I can throw
proportions off really quickly but I
might do three or four sets of chins
sorry Max rep chins slow
with slow eccentric movements the
lowering as well now slowly soundtrack
four seconds ten seconds what are we
talking about yeah usually about four or
five seconds and then slowly pulling up
Contracting whatever muscle group so all
of the movements are done trying to move
as much weight as possible as quickly as
possible on the concentric phase and
then lowering it anywhere from two to
four seconds got loading it like a
spring and then trying to explode I want
strength I want explosiveness and some
hypertrophy sneaks in because I'm
working in that you know five to eight
rep range so that's what I call torso
because it's chest shoulders back if I
every other week I'll throw in those
chins and I think everyone has a muscle
group like this where if they train it
just grows like a weed but I want to
keep proportions right strength
proportions as well and I do train my
neck that day as well I know you
wrestled I I can tell very easily
looking at somebody
whether or not they need Network or not
if your neck kind of comes down right
where your jaw is you don't need to do a
lot of neck work yeah right you don't
look like a head placed on top of a
little neck your neck is actually you
know layered Hamilton's neck is out with
the lobes of his ears genuinely yeah
yeah Danny Way great skateboard too he
trains is not quite like broke his neck
certainly yeah yeah years ago so having
a strong neck why is that so important
well it's important because you want a
strong spine and it's the upper portion
of your spine the other thing that I
notice that it does is it completely
changes my psychology to train my neck I
just naturally stand more upright yeah I
find it easier to look people in the eye
it's not hard for me to look people
directly in the eye when I speak to them
but I find I just have like my posture
and presence is just better in a chair
or standing when I train my neck and I
think it's because my head isn't let's
just use the word again it's not you
know flaccid falling of the chin towards
the chest that word just freaks
everybody out you want flaccid feet you
don't want a flaccid neck
so network is very important how do you
work in it
I actually recently bought I've been
thinking about it for decades I bought a
four-way neck machine and it's actually
I got wait you got the full four way I
was gonna get like a hammer or one of
these giant Contraptions I actually
bought and look do your homework folks
because you can hurt yourself on these
things if you get too aggressive too
quickly
I bought a four-way deck machine on
Amazon for 350 bucks I was like you know
what let me try this before spending
like five grand
works great yeah yeah nothing fancy but
you have to worry proportions I mean why
do I say this it's not just about
Aesthetics it's about in general balance
proportions are synonymous with balanced
strength which is synonymous with not
getting injured yeah you know one of the
things that looks ridiculous and frankly
is ridiculous to see these guys with big
delts wide shoulders you know long
clavicles and their head is placed on
this little popsicle on a stick well and
they look especially ridiculous there's
no other word for it in street clothes
yeah you see you know like this it looks
mutant and not in the good sense so
strong neck is great strong neck has
helped me also avoid injuries in a
number of sports it's life insurance if
you do anything any kind of martial art
where you drive a car you know been
rear-ending a car and felt fine you know
a little bit of neck soreness but train
the upper spine and lower spine so I do
some neck work at the end and the way I
do it is
take a plate wrap it in a towel so you
know with an imprint of the the weight
number on your forehead and I usually
lie on my side and I'll do it somewhere
in the 10 to 15 repetition range I'll
usually do one light warm-up and then
three works out how do you hold it on
your head
with your hand on your side it also
works your obliques somewhat you're on a
bench or on the other bench yeah you
have to be careful you know especially
getting into and out of the movement
that's how you often get injured and
then I'll lie on my stomach and this is
probably the most important one and I'll
put the plate behind my head again
wrapped in a towel and do
head raises so this is the opposite of
the text neck you're trying to get your
head sitting on top of your shoulders as
it's supposed to because everyone now is
kind of bent over in this kind of C
shape and no one's nerdy enough except
my good friend Brian McKenzie who cares
enough about his posture shout out to
Brian he's amazing work and breath work
and human performs he when he texts he
uses his phone up near his house I've
seen that so good he's like no one else
does that Ryan so the neck work comes at
the end but is absolutely critical and
whenever I don't do it for a week or two
out of laziness or or just some other
reason I start getting postural things
you start noticing elsewhere in your
body I find and this could just be I
don't think it's Placebo because it's
not something that I expect or maybe it
is now but not initially
fewer headaches
just better circulation yeah and
[Music]
better Mobility also especially if
you're spending a lot of time in front
of a computer my my rotation
even though I'm not actively training
with resistance the rotational aspect
Left Right turning your head the
mobility of the neck sort of in all
dimensions and the movement of the head
seems to improve as well for me and for
folks just one option I want to throw
out there if you train with someone or
can train with someone manual resistance
with a towel with a towel or just like
pressure on the head and doing it really
slowly like super slow style kind of
like 10 seconds 10 seconds
is very effective also I can't overstate
the importance of neck training now for
women who often don't want the aesthetic
of a larger neck yeah just use very I
would say lighter weights or or hand
based resistance you still want that
strength and balance
some women might want a big neck but in
general the two things that can and you
put some of this in the floor throw a
wig on Laird Hamilton that's my type oh
it's telling just putting it out there
ladies
one thing that in terms of Aesthetics
the two things that I think can really
throw off the most commonly desired
female aesthetic by women from what they
tell me because I trained with a number
of women is
excessive trap work upper trap work
because rounded shoulders and then
larger neck some people might want that
but in general that tends to be avoided
for guys I think the the network is you
know it's a it's so essential and for
women it's essential for a strength and
and protection of the joints reason I
will also say this and anyone who wants
to challenge me on this will do it
accordingly it actually increases your
confidence and the reason is when you're
upright you embody a different stance
I'm a big believer that the physical
stances we embody have everything to do
with the psychological stances we embody
and vice versa it's not just about
standing up straight being able to stand
up straight look people in the eyes is
something that is assisted by actually
having a head that that isn't flopping
forward all the time oh yeah so this is
a real thing from a number of
standpoints so if for whatever reason I
do the cardio workout that I mentioned
that 25 or 30 minutes of running that's
what I do but some people might do it on
the assault bike or something like that
or cycling or rower
on the Wednesday then I'll do that
Weight Workout I just described torso on
Thursday or I'll swap them so there's
some flexibility built into the week
travel
Etc by the way the cardiovascular
workouts can be done in the morning or
the evening but I always prefer to do
them in the morning and just get it done
with
then Friday is a really important day
because Friday is the day that I do a
short workout usually only about three
minutes of warm-up and about 12 minutes
of training and the goal is to get my
heart rate as high as I possibly can I
learned this from Andy Galpin just
increasing VO2 max getting those really
fast muscle fibers my favorite way to do
this is I'll get on the assault bike
which are the ones with the handles with
the fan which is not designed to keep
you cool it's designed to create
resistance folks and do 20 second on
Sprint 10 second rest 22nd on 10 seconds
Tabata type thing for six to eight
rounds and then what I like to do is
take a band and tie it to something like
a chin up bar or something and I'll
squat down and jump
and I'll do it as high jumping as I
possibly can but I actually control The
Eccentric I'm holding the band as I come
down
and so I learned from Peter attia I've
learned from Andy Galpin that our
ability to jump and land is strongly
correlated with physical longevity or
you could do broad jump so you could do
a bunch of broad jumps you could do some
hit workout and then I'm just showered
in out the door to go do my work or to
work so it's a really short workout and
then Saturday is the fun one because I'm
still enjoy this I'll go into the gym in
the morning usually it's mid-morning and
I'll do small muscle groups biceps
triceps rear delts I'll do another tip
and calf workout a little bit lighter
than the one on leg day because leg day
is coming in two days and the next day
I'm doing that long hike
so that that day is really to round out
the smaller muscle groups that need work
and I have short torso long arms and so
torso muscles grow very easily for me
get stronger easily long arms but you
know they require a little bit more work
so I like to do a dedicated day for that
same way warm up plus two to four work
sets of two to three exercises
I always include dips at some point
during the week bench steps tricep
extensions with cables basic stuff
preacher curls and incline curls so very
basic stuff but I just want to backtrack
One Step because I failed to say that
Friday the idea is to get that VO2 max
up but guess what it's also designed to
indirectly hit the legs we hit legs on
Monday oh yeah and they've recovered we
now know that protein synthesis
maximizes after these training workouts
at about 48 hours and then starts to
taper off now you read that you hear
that a lot especially on social media
and people think you have to hit a
muscle group every 48 hours but no you
hold on to the protein synthesis you
generated for another couple of days so
that Friday Sprint on the bike workout
or Sprint on a field workout and jumping
is indirectly targeting the quads and
calves and hamstrings and so you're
keeping them online for hypertrophy so
when you hear all this you might think
gosh that's a lot of working out but
we're really talking about it's a long
hike with friends or family on Sunday or
by oneself 90 minutes to three hours
you're talking about an hour workout on
Monday morning tell you about sitting in
the sauna and cold on Tuesday you're
talking about running for 20 or 30
minutes on Wednesday talking about doing
some dips and overhead presses maybe
some chins a little bit of neck work
on Thursday you're talking about doing a
12 minute workout on Friday
and you're talking about going to the
gym for an hour hour and 15 minutes more
casual kind of I don't want to call it
what it is but you could call it a
vanity workout I call it that to Joe
Rogan and he was like that's ridiculous
bicep is key muscle group and I was like
give me an example and he's like well
you know when you're grappling and
you're about to choke somebody out and I
was like okay well that's you but he's
absolutely right you know if you've ever
fixed up yeah actually I chipped my
tooth really hard once by I was trying
to fix something with a wrench and
you're pulling with your bicep and your
arm toward you and completely broke
loose and you know chipped my tooth but
keep your head out of the way good thing
you turn your neck yeah this is mostly a
falsy this one front tooth exactly I
could have knocked myself out but the
you know there's a lot of things that
you know bicep is good for forearm
strength is good for so Joe's absolutely
right but I think that when you look at
all that it's not that much time in the
gym you can do all all of that at home
there are ways to do the leg workout
even at home or in natural terrain for
the hikes and things and so it's that's
the the schedule and again if you think
about that schedule each day you're
accomplishing that endurance leg
strength cold and heat adaptation and
all the neural stuff that goes with that
torso keep the Torso strong but here
again we can say that torso work is
indirectly hitting biceps and triceps
then running for 20 years being able to
run a couple miles is a good skill and
what you find is that if you train your
legs properly and you give them enough
rest in the cold and heat really helped
too you are so strong on that 20 or 30
minute run your tips are strong you know
you have no floppy feet no back pain
you're running with with Vigor and you
know wow like this is great and so what
I've noticed in the last 24 months or so
is that I continue to get
stronger and better in each of these
areas and supposedly that's not supposed
to happen I'm 47. you know Atia the
other day said you know you and I were
both far more physically robust when we
were in our teens I was like speak for
yourself I was getting injured all the
time my body hurt I was unhappy I was
skateboarding then so I was slamming a
lot but I find that this routine has
really helped me because I think it
takes into account the slower recovery
that is just me my nervous system
doesn't recover that quickly and it also
Embraces the fact that our nervous
system and musculoskeletal system can
train for different adaptations
simultaneously across the week now the
one cap on everything that's vital and
again here a hat tip to Charles polkwin
is if you start training for longer than
60 minutes with resistance training
cortisol levels go up you start feeling
lousy you're not sleeping well or you
find you can't sleep enough
and you don't recover so keeping the
workouts relatively short has really
helped and then and then the final thing
is that
I'm a scientist slash I guess now
podcaster and I'm not interested in
being a competitive athlete so I don't
want to spend all my time training I
really want to be able to get the most
out of my training routine to feel much
better than I would otherwise when I'm
doing cognitive work and I'm a big
believer that this workout schedule
captures most if not all of the neural
circuits that one would want to to
activate perhaps the one thing missing
from it is there isn't anything in there
that's really about Dynamic movement and
multiple planes I'm not doing jiu jitsu
you know I sometimes play badminton you
know or something badmin's fun I'll do
an hour of play type stuff
non-competitive low stakes stuff big fan
of the play it away I think I learned
about that book from your podcast yeah
yeah Charlie Charlie on yeah you know
having an hour a week where you're not
trying to get fitter you're not trying
to
burn calories or accomplish any
adaptation you're just trying to play
and enjoy your ability to engage in low
stakes maybe competitive but generally
low stakes type movement where you're
very focused which is how I Define play
that's also great but that's not really
exercise
yeah yeah there's a difference between
sometimes Recreation and exercise if
we're talking about provoking
adaptations I just want to underscore a
few things one is you talked about
nervous system or you know central
nervous system CNS recovery which is I
just want to make note of that because I
think a lot of folks
think in terms of muscular recovery but
not nervous system recovery and
depending on what you're doing I mean
certainly that's that's very important
question
on a few things that I just took notes
on so Ben Patrick knees over toes I
might need to connect with him at some
point oh yeah he's trying I have
questions about tib work but before I
get to that maybe you can answer the
question that I have you mentioned
Nordic curls in passing what the hell
are Nordic girls yeah nordics are a
great semi-substitute for the glute ham
raise glute ham raise allows you to fix
your feet
and then put your head down towards the
floor and go up into a back raise and
then into what's effectively a hamstring
curl it hits the whole posterior chain
and the lower back Nordic curls or when
you either brace your heels underneath a
heavy piece of equipment or use a
lifting belt and strap yourself to a
bench or someone strong enough or heavy
enough hold your ankles down and you're
lowering down and you're touching
your hands to the floor and coming back
up or you can do the Ben Patrick Ben
Bruno Ben Bruno is another excellent
Instagram trainer and professional
trainer he trains Justin Timberlake and
a bunch of other kind of famous not kind
of famous people Justin Timberlake's Not
kind of famous he's famous and he can do
the cookie challenge which is to put a
cookie in your mouth and dip it in milk
without putting your hands so that's
incredibly hard it's interesting Ben is
deceptively strong because he's not that
large
but he's very very strong
Ben Bruno training is his new break
dancers you want to see some strong
people oh yeah deceptive yeah the yeah
b-boys so Nordic curls are great they're
they're now machines that or an
apparatus that you can buy where you can
fix your heels under something yeah even
a portable one for when you travel oh no
it goes under the door Ben Patrick AKA
knees over toes guy he has a system
called atg training I confess I didn't
subscribe to atg because I'm
I've got what I need now but
a bunch of those
portable equipment type things are
available through him
and I think he's really changed the way
that I think about how the whole body
moves and works he insists that he can
get me dunking a basketball which who
knows maybe that should be the challenge
before our next comedy our next
conversation
so Nordic curls I unbeknownst to man
because there's some other term for this
particular exercise but I have a piece
of sorenex equipment that actually is
sits in my garage and is for this exact
exercise great yeah if I had to pick
just three exercises I will never just
pick three but if I had to pick three
exercises to do and I could only do
those it would be glute ham raise slash
Nordic curl something for the posterior
chain it would be ring dips
[Music]
because then I could throw in some leg
raises too or something like that
make it multi-compound movement and I
would Sprint like if that's the only
thing I could do that's what I would do
yeah put me in a small prison cell
knocking wood let's hope that doesn't
happen that's what I asked for
scientists slash podcast or slash
inmates hopefully not listen I we talked
last time I've been behind locked doors
before it's an odd experience I want to
recreation
no so on the tip work side this may be a
question for Ben or someone more
qualified but one of the challenges that
I've had
for decades shin splints and my
dorsiflexion is actually seemingly
from a strength perspective pretty
decent ankle Mobility also pretty decent
although the left ankles have been
broken so many times that it's it's a
little crunchy but I have done training
with this fellow named Jersey gregoric
who's oh yeah holds multiple World
Records in Olympic weightlifting already
held also deceptively strong incredibly
strong I met him and his wife right yeah
she's on yellow she also has World
Records in Olympic weightlifting and
just to give you an idea folks he's got
to be in his I want to see he's probably
67-68 now and he can do a full barbell
snatch as to heals while on top of an
Indo Board which are those Balance
boards on top of Ace very dangerous and
I don't recommend trying to replicate
that but he's he's quite a physical
specimen so the point of all of that is
that my my ankle Mobility is pretty good
my dorsiflexion strength seems pretty
good but I always feel like the front of
my shins are about to explode someone
could just pop them like a balloon with
a pin and I've not figured out a way to
address this yeah I vote tib work I used
to have terrible shin splints okay yeah
terrible shin splints from and also pain
in my shins just from skateboarding
taking so many shinners as they're
called
from doing a little bit of Thai boxing
when I was in high school and college
and you know and thinking I was being
smart by conditioning my shins with Coke
bottles like I heard they did it over in
Thailand just made a mess of my shins
the tip raises have changed everything
also given me I used to think I had flat
feet but I have flat feet that's a my
source of my problem and I'd do all this
toe strengthening foot strength and
stuff all these people in the yoga
community in San Francisco were like oh
I'm going to train your feet turned out
I don't have flat feet it turns out that
The Tib my tibs were weak and so the
foot wasn't so resting in the right
position
so for me it's been a game changer also
you don't need any specialized equipment
there is that movement of resting your
shoulders against a wall
you're in a plank you're making your
body rigid your heels are on the ground
about a foot out in front of you and
then you're touching your toes down to
the floor and then back up and you're
just doing that while you're on the
phone you do 25 or 30 repetitions that
your tips will be screaming so it's as
if you're basically a statue right you
can't articulate any of your joints
minus your ankles right and you're just
standing what like a foot and a half two
feet away and then shoulders against the
shoulders getting your shoulders to the
wall but you're kind of you're leaning
like a book against a bookend right and
then exactly moving your toes all right
yeah I'm in yeah Count Me In yeah cause
I am also in the Apparently I think this
is possible the lying to myself about
the flat feet part yeah that's convinced
I have flat feet you want to hear
something really wild that has nothing
to do with Fitness but has everything to
do with metabolism and the Obesity
crisis wild metabolism and obesity just
tell me there's a very important paper
published from the University of Houston
this last year where they had people
sitting
or a couple of hours and every two or
three seconds they would keep their toe
on the ground and they would do what was
effectively a seated calf raise think
about the the jumpy kid in class or when
you've had too much coffee yeah okay
they're doing it slowly and they're
measuring the contraction of the Soleus
right the longer flatter muscle of the
calf underneath the gastro yeah turns
out that muscle is very unique it does
not
use the same fuel sources as other
muscles in the same way it's not so much
a glycogen dependent muscle
it is designed of course to carry you
very long distances or you know it's an
endurance muscle they had people do this
while seated for a couple hours a day
and they looked at glucose uptake and
they looked at overall insulin
management and there was a significant
and meaningful Improvement in insulin
sensitivity now this is not about
caloric burn this is about essentially
doing exercise while seated now I put
out some stuff about this on social
media and people understand them like a
laugh like oh that's ridiculous first of
all they call it a Soleus push-up in the
study you're like that's a seed of
Caffrey's but most people don't notice
he had calf raise them so you know Gym
Rats you know you're only laughing to
yourselves
exactly but what's very interesting is
this is something that a lot of people
can do who are
trying to improve their metabolic status
of course they should also exercise but
as the paper describes it's no surprise
why this works you know were we quote
unquote designed to walk around more or
move more during the day I don't know I
wasn't consulted in the design phase but
we were we were definitely moving around
a lot more than we probably are now yeah
but it's very interesting that this
muscle small it's only one percent of
the body's total musculature can account
for well over 15 percent well over it
depends on the person but at least 15
percent of your total energy expenditure
during the day that's insane so if
you're on a plane like this thing of
bouncing your knee or doing this thing
again is actually a meaningful it's not
a replacement for exercise but in terms
of its metabolic impact
is Meaningful I find that really
interesting and perhaps of all the
things that we'll discuss today if
you're unwilling to try that then your
bar foreign
[Music]
exactly and don't get on kids about
bouncing their knees in class teachers I
was one such kid
all right so we've covered a bunch of
exercise and
a number of things as fundamental
pillars that you've doubled down on
anything that you've changed your mind
on okay well one of them was the fact
that I always believed fluffy that we
couldn't that I had flat feet I also
believed that we couldn't obtain
multiple exercise adaptations at once
right we can't yes because I tracked my
numbers I'm not super neurotic but I
keep a you know handwritten training
journal or at the end of the day I'll I
generally can remember what I did in the
gym and didn't do we're on a run and I'm
improving over time so that's great I I
thought I would kind of had hit my Peak
ability and I was it was all downhill
from here but I feel much better how do
you track if you track like the Tabata
for instance you're looking at wattage
are you looking at anything or is it
more subjective I tend to add another
round or two I just do a little bit more
work or go a little bit harder I tend to
like to do things pretty subjectively
when it comes to exercise like I my
calendar like for legs it'll say tib
calf him
quad and I'll put level anywhere from
level one to level ten level 10 would be
the workout with like four straps and
drops that's just all out I rarely if
ever do those but typically I'm trying
to make that work out at least a level
7.5 to 9. and generally the shorter
workouts are the harder ones
occasionally just because of schedules
or I'm not feeling great I'll do that
Wednesday run and it'll end up being a
you know 15 minute jog or something and
I'll just say level five lame or
something like that like I didn't you
know or something like that and then you
know and then push a little bit harder
the next day so I'm kind of my own coach
I'm sort of observing myself rather than
getting really deep into the metrics but
I'm always trying to put a little bit
more weight on the bar or go slower with
the repetition
or add a set or a rep or two or all
three so let's hone in on sleep my
perennial favorite and the bane of my
well-being depending on the quality but
last we spoke I remember you spoke about
I think it was magnesium three and eight
but genin and there may have been one or
two other Lucky Charms in there right
are those still the Holy Trinity for
your sleep or do you have other things
that you've added things you've
subtracted what is your current cocktail
with the understanding that as much as
people want to fix everything with
silver bullets light exposure in the
morning exercise all these are
contributors to good good quality sleep
I still use the same sleep stack so it's
magnesium three and eight
spell t-h-r e-o-n-a-t
ionine and apogenin and I've added every
once in a while I'll take 900 milligrams
of myoinositol
myoinositol has a rich literature
Association name Mayo is in muscle why
Maya question yeah it must be yeah so
it's amino acid
but it can be a neurotransmitter mimetic
extensive literature on inositol for
improving insulin sensitivity there's
also something called D chiro inositol
which is important for female fertility
we can talk about that but what I've
added in the 900 milligrams myoinositol
for is I do sometimes like many people
wake up at three in the morning to use
the restroom and although there's a
simple solution to that that I just
recently learned that really works and
I'll share it in a moment catheter
it helps me fall back asleep after that
and I am tracking my sleep because I
sleep on an eight sleep and that has
good sleep tracking ability what Atiya
has taught me that a lot of the
wristbands and rings for tracking sleep
while they can be quite good and are
quite good whoops and auras being the
two most popular ones
they can get movement wrong because of
movement of Limbs whereas the eight
sleep seems to really capture slow wave
sleep rapid eye movement sleep ratios
really well yeah I use both a sleep and
Aura at the moment yeah yeah so the the
myonositol it has has helped quite a bit
with that going back to sleep thing one
way to not wake up to urinate so much in
the middle of the night I learned from a
colleague is it turns out that it's not
just how much fluid you drink which
dictates whether or not you need to
urinate because that's sort of a duh
it's also how quickly you ingest that
fluid if you gulp fluid down it actually
because of the way fluid is absorbed it
actually in the kidney
the way filtration occurs in the kidney
the way it signals to the bladder is
that you makes you have to go to the
bathroom fairly urgently so if you have
your final beverage of the day sip it
don't gulp it you know
for morning hydration the opposite is
true you actually want to gulp down
quite a lot of liquid in the morning you
can absorb quite a lot of liquid in the
morning there's a I'm reading this
really nerdy review
in nature
has this wonderful review series on
circadian rhythms in the kidney your
kidney is not the same organ first thing
in the morning as it is at night this is
what circadian biologists have been
shouting for a long time every organ is
this way but you want to hydrate pretty
heavily first thing in the morning and
then over the day you can titrate off
that liquid so I'm going to ask you to
pick some favorite children here so you
got them you got the Magnesium three and
eight l-theanine
apogenin which am I understanding
correctly that is effectively chamomile
tea on steroids High concentration
chamomile extract all right got it and
then the myo inositol myoinositol all
right 900 milligrams which turns out to
be it's a big pill but turns out to be
pretty low dose for insulin sensitivity
they give and for depression they give
people up to five grams of myoinosity a
day okay but it's a mild sedative so I
don't know how people get away with that
I'll take the four of those I will
occasionally be so tiredone before my
workout yeah occasionally I'm so tired
that I'll wake up with the pills in my
hand or on the night skin so I don't
think I'm dependent on them in any way I
will just briefly say because today
we've been talking about foundational
tools kind of the foundations of let me
just slip in the question and then no no
you're good yeah the question is if you
could only choose two of those oh easy
mag 3na and apogenic okay yeah got it
yeah theanine is not going to be good
for people that have very robust dreams
or nightmares
because it will increase
how Vivid your dreams are so night
Walkers night terrors that kind of thing
for those of you that have sleepwalking
night Walkers
sorry and I didn't mean to interrupt you
this is something I I'm working on is my
colleague at Stanford Carol dweck told
me that it's a sign of enthusiasm for
the conversation oh yeah no I apologize
oh are you kidding I mean I'm not gonna
throw stones in my glass house here I
interrupt constantly
but you were talking about the kidneys
you're saying not the same organ in the
morning as it is at night this is what
circadian biologists have been screwing
from the rooftops and now
that's coming home to roost in these
papers that you're reading or maybe it's
a meta and else I don't know and you're
saying sipping water at night or just
slower intake gulping in the morning and
I I threw your your train of thought off
the rails all good I mean basically you
want to look at the first half of your
day very differently than the second
half of your day morning part of your
day you want sunlight or bright
artificial light
why it increases cortisol 50 above
Baseline you want cortisol High early in
the day and you want it low low low
later in the day not because it disrupts
sleep but because it's late shifted
cortisols associated with depression
screws up your immune system have it
late shifted beautiful work from Bob
sapolsky and David Spiegel at Stanford
School of Medicine have shown that
hydration caffeine sunlight movement
bright light if you can't get sunlight
early in the day you really want what
are called the catecholamines which are
dopamine epinephrine norepinephrine and
you want cortisol which is a glucose
corticoid elevated in the early part of
the day that's what's going to give you
energy Focus alertness all that great
stuff throughout the day and then you
want to taper that stuff off as the day
goes on now recent data have shown that
if you want to improve your rapid eye
movement sleep why would you want to do
that well rapid eye movement sleep is
when you get the emotional the unpacking
of emotions from previous day memories
yeah read or listen to
our usual friend Matt Walker right I
mean how do you get more rapid eye
movement sleep high intensity interval
training early part of the day or
cycling appears to greatly improve
different stages of sleep as well
compared to running although running I
don't know I think it has to do with the
central pattern generator thing high
intensity interval training I mean
you're pedaling on the bike or you're
sprinting so it's repetitive but it's
not repetitive for long enough that
you're engaging certain brain circuits
so and it's going to deplete different
neurotransmitter systems it's going to
engage the endorphin system rather than
the dopamine I wonder if it's also a
study bias in the sense that it's so
much easier
to get
your slaves AKA like undergrads or grad
students or whoever recruited in a
university setting to sit on a bike yeah
so if you have a hundred studies with
bikes and you have five studies with
running that maybe it's sort of a
selection bias in some in some respect
because there's just such a higher
volume of studies I don't know I don't
know I love bicycling when I can be
upright you know I think you're Dutch
bicycle you know moving through a city
seeing things optic flow seeing which we
know shuts down the amygdala to some
extent it suppresses activity amygdala
it's beautiful you see things you see
people how anyone in the world could
want to be hunched over in a partial C
position and pedaling as you as one is
on a road bike I have it's just I have a
zero minus one interest in doing that it
sounds horrible and then I heard it
gives you all these like prostate issues
and it can give them erectile
dysfunction I'm like you know because
from the pain they now put grooves in
the seats because you know I just think
like why would anyone be a cyclist this
is terrible having a pool cue shoved
into like your perennium for hours at a
time isn't good for you no hunched over
Legacy and and I realize that you know I
have many friends who are triathletes
and cyclists so I realize there's really
an Allure there moving fast through
space feels really good but also the
danger of cars and like yeah so cycle
riding a bicycle recreationally to me
makes sense as does you know walking or
running or skateboarding or whatever but
to me cycling hunched over like that
just seems like a dreadful form of
exercise but that's just me so let's go
from the Dreadful
to the sublime perhaps we we mentioned a
couple of supplements and I don't want
to fixate on that but I follow my own
curiosity here and there's a list here
so on the omegas because we discussed
omega-3 fatty acids EPA DHA
and I am increased my intake
I'm so curious to know because I do
observe seemingly a very consistent
Improvement not in mood and sleep
however I've tried multiple Brands and
I've tried to do the homework and look
at the various like certificates of
analysis to make sure that I'm not you
know eating rancid garbage
I end up getting mild nausea after like
a week of
I suppose higher intake maybe if I'm
taking
I might be getting the the amount off
but maybe two grams total something like
that and liquid or capsule form in
capsule form with food or without food
that's a great question I I probably
wasn't even paying attention although I
tend to take
fat with food so probably with food or
maybe just before food yeah I I'd be
curious to know anyone on the internet
if you're listening to this if you've
experienced anything similar because I
see the benefits and then let's just
call it five to seven days in I just get
this like low grade
nausea almost like a motion sickness and
then I stop for a washout period and
then I'm fine and I'm like God so you
know it's the fish oil a bummer yeah
yeah there's some I mean obviously some
great high quality fish oils out there
there's for liquid the Carlson's Brands
the ones that are lemon flavored to make
them less fishy is gonna be the most
cost effective way to get fish oil okay
has to be refrigerated after opening but
that's definitely the most cost
effective way in here we do have a you
know supplement affiliate for the
podcast but that's just that it's not
them but that's just the truth what is
your dosage Target for
Omega-3s or EPA specifically minimum one
gram per day of EPA okay minimum
sometimes do you take it in one dose or
split doses I take it it ends up being
three capsules
with my big meal of the day which tends
to be a midday meal and then I take a
tablespoon of the Carlson's oil and
people gasp when I say this but I
actually like it on my oatmeal with salt
I you know I when I've spent time stir
it in like Iceland and the Scandinavia I
had these little shots of like cod liver
oil and so on I can do that but on top
of the oatmeal no I'm telling you it's
really good oh and I hate sardines I
despise sardines I despise anything
smoked flavor I'm really boring and I
absolutely loathe anchovies like fishy
oil smell yeah I can't even really like
eating fish I like sushi that's about it
but even there I don't even like
I'm a good person to go to sushi with
because you get all all the eel all the
uni you know
I just want the Yellow Tail and the
Maguro yeah the least defensive fish
available at least I'm not ordering
chicken teriyaki and just so people are
hearing it from you and not not from me
not to say it's even the same thing what
are the primary benefits That You
observe or that are supported by
literature either or
with the intake of say one gram minimum
of EPA per day mood antidepressant
effects absolutely clear and there are
so many clinical trials supporting that
people can get away with taking lower
doses of antidepressants or even coming
off antidepressants of course always you
know check with your psychiatrist before
you do that by increasing their omega-3
intake above one gram per day even as
high as three grams per day I guess a
question review I remember last time we
spoke we were we chatted a bit about
ability for
the gut let's just say it says some
people refer to it as the second brain
to sense the intake of
sugar fat and a handful of other things
what is the mechanism of action by which
the EPA is affecting mood is that known
or I think so it's a it's probably
two-pronged one the EPA is a fundamental
structural lipid or neuronal membranes
and for
the neurons in particular that release
neuromodulators such as serotonin and
dopamine
that's one the other is that these
neuropod cells in the gut
as they're called
sense as you point out sugar
essential fatty acids essential amino
acids and Signal via the vagus to the
dopamine centers of the brain so your
gut is subconsciously signaling to your
brain what kinds of nutrients are coming
into your system yeah and when you have
a lot of flavorful food
or and or high caloric food but it's not
high in nutrients it sets that system
totally out of whack because there's an
increase in dopamine for sure from the
taste of the food that's not matched by
that subconscious parallel signal by the
way this this is not
woo biology this is coming from the
Laboratories of Diego Borges at Duke
University School of Medicine Charles
Zucker who's Howard who's medical
investigator at Columbia University has
done this for sugar sensing and a number
of other Laboratories have shown that
this pathway from the subconscious
signaling from the vagus to the dopamine
centers of the brain are driving in an
appetite for certain kinds of foods
however when these neurons these
neuropod cells in the gut are quote
unquote satisfied they're seeing the the
nutrients they want to see they signal
to the brain dopamine release within the
brain but they also are signaling
satiety and that's really what you want
so in many ways we are a essential amino
acid essential fatty acid foraging
machine it just also so happens that at
least in the short term sugar will
trigger the same pathway this is also
why people who increase their intake of
Omega-3s get above that one gram per day
of epas
or who take small amounts of L-glutamine
reduce their sugar Cravings you're
activating the same neurons you're
giving the alternative stimulus so the
L-glutamine is vis-a-vis the the
neuropods likely yeah that hasn't been
directly established but it's long been
known that increasing intake of certain
essential amino acids can reduce craving
for sweets and whenever people say how
do I kill my Sweet Craving well it's not
a conventional approach but you could
take
you could get a quality Branch Sheen
amino acid or essential amino acid
powder which sometimes have some
non-coloric sweetener or something and
fruity taste and mix it in there people
find oh yeah I don't actually crave
chocolate the same way or I mean in my
opinion a little bit of dark chocolate
is wonderful every once in a while so I
don't want to give the impression you're
not never supposed to have sugar but
there are people who very much feel a
slave to their sugar Cravings yeah so
giving these neurons the alternative
stimulus really helps and you're getting
the effectively the same dopamine
release this makes sense evolutionarily
why we would crave essential fatty acids
and essential amino acids yeah totally
this is also why the non-mediators won't
relate but a really great steak is very
satisfying despite the fact that has no
glucose essentially there are other
people who feel quite good whether or
not they're healthy or not as if we
could talk about but who feel quite good
just eating steak right now I'm not one
of those people but if you had to pick a
food that would keep you feeling good
and would repair the tissues of your
body and would give you enough fats to
keep going and protein synthesis Etc if
you had to feed your children you would
give them a steak you would not give
them a sweet potato yeah and if you look
at the amount of food that one eats when
given as much meat as they want fatty
meat in particular not gross fatty meat
high quality fatty meat versus
carbohydrates I mean you just look at
you're quite satisfied after a certain
amount of protein intake so I'm not
pushing people towards a carnivore diet
I don't follow a carnivore diet but I do
think that our nervous system
from the gut to the brain is a is a
sensing and foraging system that
subconsciously and lets our brain know
aha I've got enough of what I need and
now I can stop eating if I want to
so we're gonna LeapFrog from
delicious fish I think move for me might
be to go to
just pure liquid refrigerated try that I
mean who the hell knows just to try
something even if the expiration date
looks fine maybe I just got a couple of
bad batches who knows or maybe it's the
capsules themselves I mean there's so
many things go into these capsule
formulas and then there's shelf life and
all of that yeah
gut health you know overall it's hard
for most people to do what they need to
for their gut yeah in addition all the
things to avoid like too frequent use of
antibiotics and things of that Source
it's pretty clear that one
serving of fermented foods a day is not
going to be enough that you need three
or four servings of low sugar fermented
food so natto for people that can
stomach it good luck you know sauerkraut
kimchi a good Bulgarian yogurt I like
these really sour Bulgarian yogurts
they're so good Bulgaria oh there's this
amazing Bulgarian yogurt you have to try
this stuff it is so good except they
don't have the full fat one in
particular what makes the Bulgarian
yogurt so magical I can remember the
name of this brand we'll put it in the
show it's so good but I don't want
people that they run out because they
only put two or three of these in every
Whole Foods yeah I'm buying those two or
three so of the full fat ones but it's
hard for most people to get that much
low sugar fermented food per day and so
most people just don't do it and and
then high-dose probiotics are very
expensive need to be refrigerated yeah
so that's why I think the ag1 you know
checks off a number of boxes there but
if people can ingest low sugar fermented
foods that's going to serve them really
really well so say the data from Justin
sonnenberg's lab yeah Chris Gardner's
lab enjoy or kilo a day of natto tell me
how that goes this stuff is so slimy
it's so wicked I mean that is there are
two things that I've yeah I've lived in
Japan and was there's an exchange
student so on they're at least well
let's see three food items that Japanese
people find hilarious to watch
foreigners try to eat
natto is definitely number one it's just
like spider web cobweb stink it's so
gnarly I can eat it but it's it's not my
favorite even to this day
umeboshi and other types of like pickled
super super salty plums and so on that's
another one and then I would say uni
also before especially before it was
really making the rounds in the U.S like
the first time a foreign would go over
and just get like the seagull poo on top
of the sushi rice it's so hardcore uni
is what I'm talking about this
consistency-wise it's very very similar
it just feels like it's a it's like a
tongue
yeah it's not my it's not my favorite
people but people love it some people do
people are told that it's an aphrodisiac
it's the best way to sell anything
that's right so I wanted to ask you
because I have a couple of notes here
this is
if I'm pronounce that correctly but the
one I want to ask you about first is
actually if I'm getting the
pronunciation
correctly rhodiola rosea Rhoda yellow
rose impressive supplement so please
tell me more about this because I have
heard in my conversations with athletes
over the years of people using this for
various endurance purposes
altitude acclimation but I don't know if
any of that has any foundation so
rhodiola rose has a really interesting
compound because it falls into this
category of what people call adaptogens
but normally when you hear adaptogens
first of all that's a very vague term it
doesn't actually mean anything specific
it means an ability to adapt generally
or specifically no one's really
pinpointed what that means but typically
the adaptogens are going to reduce
cortisol so for instance ashwagandha is
very potent suppressor of cortisol
there's some evidence it can indirectly
increase testosterone but probably
through suppression of cortisol since
those are in the same synthesis pathway
ashwagandha is an adaptogen ashwagandha
because it lowers cortisol should
probably be taking late day not early
day because you want cortisol High yep
ashwagandha as a cortisol suppressing
adaptogen probably also should not be
taken in high amounts not lower low
amounts but in high amounts meaning you
know four to six hundred milligrams
prior to exercise because the whole goal
of exercise is to trigger the adaptation
through a spike in cortisol or one of
the goals
rhodiola rosea's very interesting
compound because it's an adaptogen in
that it greatly reduces perceived effort
and allows for greater power output and
endurance output as you pointed out a
moment ago
but it does not do that by suppressing
cortisol
so 200 milligrams of rhodiola rosea
prior to say a resistance training
workout or even on one of your skitoring
days you will notice you have more Vigor
you can just go longer and your
perceived effort is much lower and it's
kind of striking what is it doing now
this is interesting it's kind of
striking how after the workout you don't
feel as depleted that perhaps the main
reason I started taking is I found I
could train harder but then I suffered
quite a lot from a post-exercise dip in
energy especially if I ate big meal I no
longer experience that if I take
rhodiola rosea and 30 to 60 minutes
before workout the effects of it last
about four hours
so what's happening during that workout
it's clearly having an effect on the
central nervous system by reducing the
total amount of adrenaline that's
released or the efficacy of adrenaline
epinephrine during high intensity effort
or lung duration effort so what this
effectively means is you're in principle
one is able to generate the same amount
of effort without the same amount of
energy depleting neurochemicals I mean
epinephrine norepinephrine help you
generate energy but there's always a
trough afterwards always and so if you
can generate the same amount of physical
output in the absence of x amount of
adrenaline or norepinephrine then you're
essentially better off it also seems to
catalyze recovery better I would not
take it more
often than just before training however
because there are a few studies showing
that the effects of it can kind of taper
off if you're taking it all day every
day now would that be true for say
ashwagandha let's just say someone's
taking it before sleep would they want
to cycle off of that how would you think
about cycling
if recommended yeah low dose of
ashwagandha you know 25 50 milligrams a
day taking continuously no problem I
actually think ag1 has low dose of
ashwagandha in it but when people are
taking ashwagandha to offset high stress
of you know mental or physical stuff or
both for a period in life I'd say after
about two weeks you want at least two
weeks off you really don't want to
suppress cortisol chronically unless
there's some clinical reason for that
yeah rhodiola rosea is probably the best
addition to my kind of
physical performance stack that I've
added in a long time and it's really
striking I mean I think so much so that
people could try it and it really does
seem to work the first time and every
time for me
if it doesn't work for you the first
time if you you know all other things
being equal you got a decent night's
sleep you're doing everything the same
way you normally would and you take
Rodeo Rose and you don't really notice
much of an effect
you know you might try and increase the
dose slightly and and give it another go
and what was the dosage range 200
milligrams 200 million yeah that's what
I'll take and I found that to be really
striking now I'm not going to take that
before like like a long Sunday jog or a
hike I mean I might but chances are I'm
not going to do it before leg workout
I'm gonna do it before a hit workout I'm
mainly doing it to
make sure that I can train really hard
and then go do other things really hard
too again that's not a competitive
athlete I loathe the experience of
training really hard and then feeling
like I gave everything to that training
session and therefore I don't have much
energy or Focus to give to the other
anything else yeah yeah and I think most
people are like that are you still
taking the tonkat Ali and the fedosia
agrestis and for those who are not
familiar because I think we may have
made mention of this in our last
conversation but just in brief what are
these two things do tongat Ali is an
Indonesian ginseng there's a Malaysian
version too but you want the Indonesian
one if you want to pursue these effects
which are it's known to decrease sex
hormone binding globulin which frees
testosterone
which is important in both men and women
it turns out in women
there's more testosterone circulating in
a healthy woman post-puberty woman than
there is estrogen Peter Tia taught me
this have you normalized for nanograms
per deciliter women have more
testosterone than estrogen healthy women
do so testosterone is associated with
libido ability and desire to generate
effort mood Etc in men and women
probably the best way to describe
testosterone's effects are
it makes effort to feel good so
um Tonga Ali frees up more testosterone
so it mild libido enhancer for some more
extreme for others increases energy will
increase you know feelings of well-being
and typically the dosages are 400
milligrams a day
in single dose or divide doses with or
without food taken early in the day
before noon or 2 pm because it can
increase energy you don't want to
disrupt your sleep there are a number of
good sources of it we can provide links
to a couple of those sources
and fedogiograssis is a Nigerian shrub
it's taken from a Nigerian shrub and it
stimulates the release of luteinizing
hormone
which is going to come out of the
pituitary
and in women will stimulate anything
that comes from Downstream of
luteinizing hormone in the ovary
typically estrogen maybe even
testosterone to some extent and in men
it will increase testosterone output
from the testes by way of increasing
luteinizing hormone maybe subtle
increase in estrogen as well this is
important men hear that
something increases estrogen they go oh
I don't want that well keep in mind that
if you flat line your estrogen so if men
are taking an astrozole or crushing
their estrogen their libido is going to
be zero yeah
their cognitive ability will be
diminished estrogen is important in both
medical cardio protective isn't it
cardio protective the endothelial cells
we think of our blood vessels and Our
arteries and capillaries as tubes but
they're really tubes imagine Silly Putty
kind of rolled out Plato made into
little flat sheets and then rolled up to
comprise those two so it's many many
endothelial cells that make up those
tubes and the flexibility of those tubes
is very important obviously you don't
want them rigid
you need them to expand and contract as
needed and estrogen is important for for
some of that signaling leading to that
malleability of the endothelial cells
the dogea agrestis is typically taken in
dosages of 300 to 600 milligrams per day
with or without food doesn't seem to
matter if it's early day late day
there's some evidence in rats it can be
toxic to the testicular tissue but
that's in very very high concentrations
and the it's interesting the the number
of studies on humans for both Tonga Ali
and fedoja have greatly expanded since
our last conversation and especially for
tongali there's quite good support
safety margins are good within the
dosage ranges that we've talked about
I've heard of people taking up to a gram
a day of Tonga Ali that just makes me
cringe I think taking herbal compounds
in very high concentrations it's going
to be risky no matter what because these
things can trigger immune responses so
you know 400 milligrams of Tonga Ali 300
600 milligrams of fedocia taken daily
should be fine I don't cycle them and
never have some people cycle the fedogia
why they're afraid why don't I cycle
them yeah because they just keep working
well I mean Louie Simmons could have
said that about it right well it's too
yeah so a couple of reasons I do blood
work twice a year yeah liver enzymes are
included there we can talk about
fertility perhaps it if you want today
in the last year because of my age in
the fact that I don't have children yet
but I'm cognizant of the fact that I do
want them at some point
I started doing I got really down the
rabbit hole interesting figure of speech
of sperm analysis including everything
from DNA fragmentation to out to
increase sperm numbers and motility and
quality and egg quality you're a
Gambling Man if you're making your
swimmers world class but you don't want
kids
well it's all about readiness I suppose
what is it that in the SEAL Teams they
say like you fall not to the level of
your your hope which is your level of
your preparation you you do not rise to
the level of your hopes but false level
your preparation that's actually a quote
from archa Locus who is a Greek poet and
I believe philosopher also but yes also
widely used in the Special Forces teams
so I've been monitoring sperm parameters
freezing sperm because I might want to
do IVF someday with somebody you know
this kind of thing
or have conceived naturally but and
because yeah we're talking about
tools supplements Etc as it relates to
vitality and fertility
I think there is a way to optimize for
both of those things so I don't cycle
them because I haven't felt a need to or
seen a need to some people choose to
just take a week off from for Dojo every
once in a while or go five days on two
days off and people should do what makes
them comfortable males will notice an
effective for Doja it actually will
increase testicular size somewhat and a
density and that's just because of the
increase of the LH luminizing hormone is
going to stimulate avocado pits
it's going to depend on where you start
and we'll do a number of things related
to increasing luteinizing hormone
similar although not to the same extent
as something like taking HCG human
chorionics well that's what I was going
to ask if you were to inject yourself
with HCG you would probably cycle at
some point or maybe not I don't know you
tell me I've done experiments with HCG I
think you have two I have to yeah I mean
it definitely will increase sperm volume
and significantly yeah significantly I
mean HCG is essentially luteinizing
hormone oh yeah you know there's
actually a movement within the
testosterone augmentation world now to
we don't want to go too far down this
path but so-called trt replacement
therapy a lot of people are interested
in what I call Tat which is augmentation
therapy so that's a Rebrand you know we
were talking about well yeah Patagonian
tooth fish goes to Chilean sea bass and
taking roid's goes to testosterone
augmentation therapy yeah I mean I think
every male should be aware that taking
exogenous testosterone like testosterone
cypionate or otherwise is going to
suppress your endogenous testosterone
however there are people that want to do
that I think one of the goals for most
people is to neither be
out of range you know there are a lot of
people who don't want to be bodybuilders
and take so-called steroids but
obviously even estrogens are steroids
yeah sure and cortisol is a
corticosteroid so but to be high end of
normal range right high end of normal so
if the range is 300 nanograms deciliter
all the way up to 1200 or 900 in some
countries it depends you know being
somewhere between you know 600 and 900 I
think it's going to be preferable for
most people and Tonga alien fidoji
aggresses I think represent a good place
to start if you don't want to pursue
these other more aggressive
is particularly interesting to me
because I almost always have very high
range
total testosterone but my free
testosterone is low and my sex hormone
binding globulin is high which itself is
not necessarily A Bad Thing the 900
milligrams myoinositol can also increase
free testosterone indirectly through
mechanisms that aren't entirely clear
okay there are also some other ways if
people want to tickle these pathways
you know Sheila G right
fulvic acid
Sheila G is a mineral pitch it's used in
ayurvedic medicine I thought that was a
1980s lead vocalist okay it stimulates
the release of FSH a follicle
stimulating hormone so you have LH and
FSH coming out of the pituitary and LH
will stimulate testosterone production
via the lighting cells of the testes the
FSH is going to stimulate
spermatogenesis by increasing what's
called Androgen binding protein which is
the protein that the testosterone binds
to which then is going to give rise to
more sperm at risk of I never want to do
kind of a podcast plug on another
podcast especially not yours I did a
four and a half hour episode on male and
female fertility that goes through
essentially the ovulatory cycle and the
sperban Genesis cycle and then all the
do's and do Nots for both men and women
who wish to conceive either now or in
the future or who do not wish to
conceive children but want to use
fertility as a proxy for Vitality which
is something by the way I have to say I
have to credit you for years ago you
said you know basically if you optimize
for fertility you're optimizing for
Vitality so there again I want to just
thank you because that's an extremely
efficient but also extremely Sage way to
think about optimizing for Vitality so
it's not just about wanting to have kids
it's about maintaining all your
biological systems at their right tuning
super helpful proxy super helpful what
in this case what do you mean by
vitality
waking up feeling well enough to want to
begin your day
with enough energy to complete your day
and
to be able to have
to move back and forth along the
Continuum of
driven and relaxed eliminating
relationships to others as a component
for the moment of course it is a
component setting in that aside rather
what I just described to me is the
definition of mental health the ability
to lean into effort but also to relax
and restore your system
and to feel good about what you're doing
and being able to move from driven to
reflective and these kinds of things
so many people we know don't want to
give a geographical they all left the
bay area anyway there I just said it was
a bear you know successful but miserable
but we knew a lot of those or people
that can't seem to get enough energy to
focus and get get down a path of a
Pursuit so you want both that's Vitality
to me and this is getting kind of Easter
in philosophy which is more your domain
than mine and I'm always eager to learn
here but you know when you think about
Chi or kind of dopamine or Life Energy
the desire to create things in the world
including Offspring but just to birth
ideas birth businesses birth
relationships Earth podcasts whatever it
is is is essentially from the same place
of having some idea in mind and trying
to construct that overcoming fear your
Notions of fear setting become really
relevant here
Etc and so Vitality has a lot to do with
the ability to generate effort with
feeling like at least if not a fast
upward spiral at least a slow upward
spiral and certainly not a slow downward
spiral downwards I'll take any of the
overalls right I mean I think you know
I'm around a lot of graduate students
and postdocs and you see how an early
success like publishing a paper early on
in one's career creates an upward spiral
around the whole concept of effort
thereafter you see this in dating and
relationships you see how an early
failure can set people along a downward
spiral and so I think that having Drive
comes from the catecholamines it's
dopamine epinephrine norepinephrine
ensure you need the serotonergic systems
and the endogenous opioid systems that
smooth things out but in the absence of
that get up and go I mean we wouldn't be
here there's no again I wasn't consulted
the design phase but you can be pretty
sure that this is what allows any animal
or human to move toward a milestone so
I'm going to ask you
yet again a lazy but perhaps
productive question that is will satisfy
my own curiosity
omegasia agrestis and rhodiola rosea you
get to pick two which would you pick
omegas and Tonga Ali okay yeah if I
think about fundamental
kind of Baseline supplementation things
that are hard to get from food but that
represent
key micronutrients that really move
multiple needles in the right direction
it's going to be getting above that one
gram per day threshold of epas so omegas
it's also going to be anything that
moves the hormone system toward the
green zone which is going to be Tonka
Ali now of course doing all the other
things right trying to get sleep
exercise sleep movement nutrient
sunlight all that in fact there's a
really wonderful study out of Israel
that showed that if people got 20
minutes
three times a week of sun exposure to
their skin their face and they remove
their shirts or if there was women that
were tank tops and shorts for both men
and women three times a week significant
increases in test free testosterone
and this was afternoon Zone it wasn't
Morning Sun increases in free
testosterone and estrogen and
significant increases in libido also if
you chart out the amount of free
testosterone across the months even in
places that aren't really far north
you're going to see significant
variations in free testosterone in men
and women
toward the summer spring and summer
months so we're somewhat seasonal and
some people robustly seasonal depending
on your your ancestry so that sunlight
thing is real and the mechanism just so
that people aren't like go get sunlight
he's just saying sunlight again is that
the keratinocytes which are a component
of the skin signal through this for you
nerds that like me the p53 pathway and
impinge on pituitary to Signal
luteinizing hormone and follicle
stimulating hormone release it's so
interesting because what we think of the
as the skin which is protecting our
organs and you know place to put tattoos
and earrings and jewelry and stuff is
actually an endocrine organ the skin is
a hormone producing organ hence the
vitamin D thing and everything else yeah
a lot of fat cells too which a lot of
people don't think about yeah so
definitely the omegas and Tonga Ali
rhodiola Rose is great to enhance
workouts yeah fedogias definitely up
it's a it's a boost on the hormone
system for sure I have a friend who is
single now he's in a great relationship
we can't say it was because the fedogio
but he was taken from doji and he's like
I gotta stop taking this stuff because
uh he was flying solo at that he was
like this is just really it's really
intrusive and not interested because he
was just humping the walls I don't know
if we want to go here you know there's
this whole online community now about
semen retention and things like that
he's not part of that Community but
there's this idea that well we'll just
be we're adults here I mean there's this
idea that speak for yourself I mean look
in the journals of sexual health yeah
and I'm really interested in in sexual
health and Urological Health there's a
ton of interesting stuff on pelvic floor
this stuff just isn't often discussed
what you find is that a masturbation for
women turns out to their self-reported
Notions of well-being of mood of immune
system function of quote unquote knowing
their bodies and what gives them
pleasure Etc all increase if you look at
the data in Men in terms of masturbation
and here we're talking about
masturbation to the point of ejaculation
in men they report lower mood less
willingness to pursue relationships
shocker you know they're home watching
porn right so we have to be very careful
with statements like masturbation is bad
or or something like that because that's
not true it's going to be genders well
we should say stay out of that
discussion biological sex dependent
because yeah it's a clearer ground we'll
just leave it at that and then there is
this whole notion that a whole
generation of young males are becoming
important addicted to masturbation
addicted but can't look someone in the I
asked them out on a date or learn how to
navigate healthy consensual sex yeah
right and they're not doing Network so
they can't look anyone in the eye
they've got flaccid feet and they don't
do nothing
yeah I mean and here I'm not trying to
create Notions of like hyper mails we're
really just talking about a radical
shift in the way that Sexual Health has
evolved over the last 10 years because
of the accessibility of hardcore
pornography its relation to the dopamine
system yeah you know so here I'm not
trying to be Evangelical or anything
like that I'm just saying
these are serious neurotransmitter slash
hormone systems and a whole generation
of males is
making themselves sated enough to not
actually pursue a number of what used to
be considered Milestones toward
the transition between young adulthood
and true adulthood and you know his
birth rates are low dating is low oh
yeah sex you know a few people are
having a lot more sex so this is great
for the people out there who are
comfortable in social interactions right
anyway we we don't want to go down that
path too far but these are deeply wired
systems yeah do they who have much much
will be given yeah so for those of you
willing to date and find relationship
thank you for Dozier so before we move
on I do want to ask you about because
we're chatting a little bit before we
started recording psychedelics and your
your current and developing thoughts
on on that or any commentary you'd like
to add but before we get to that since
you were talking about fertility
understanding people can go to the the
Dances with Wolves episode where you
cover all things comprehensively but
we're talking about a number of tools in
the form of these supplements for
lack of better way to phrase it goosing
the system right these are ways to
augment certain certain endocrine
functions or the sort of
composition say of of free versus
bounded testosterone Etc
where did you end up after doing your
research on environmental endocrine
disruptors or
things that we should be subtracting
rather than adding because it's hard for
me as someone who is say certainly a
non-specialist in reproductive Health to
find the time or even maybe just the the
dedication to sort this signal from the
noise with all that because there's a
lot of hysterics too there's a lot of
nonsense out there where did you land
with what are important if anything to
be mindful of or subtract
so so for cutting through that foreign
I think people should listen to to this
podcast but specifically just to hone in
on this yeah it was designed for
individuals or couples who are thinking
about these issues and and also
or in particular for women who are
interested in banking eggs yep you know
like most women don't know that cut off
after which you can't freeze eggs you
can only freeze embryos so in California
if you're 42 years old or younger you
can freeze eggs
might meet someone later and decide you
want to take children or use a donor
after 42 I think it's at 42 and a half
you can only
create embryos and freeze those they're
just not the eggs are on average are
just too aged out
males if you want to be a sperm donor
you know ideally you're going to do that
before 45. sperm donor or you might want
to do IVF someday now there is a
significant increase in the incidence of
autism with each half decade for the
father you know so as you go from you
know 30 to 35 to 40.
the sperm age matters but
the increases still incredibly small
overall so it's not something you can
really point to and say oh it's a sperm
you know or it's the egg for that matter
okay now do's and don'ts we can now
easily look back to the beginning of our
discussion it's very clear that quality
sleep on a regular basis sunlight
keeping stress in check healthy
relationships over all of that is going
to support sperm health and egg health
no question about that it's also clear
that getting sufficient omega-3 fatty
acids is going to support sperm health
and egg Health I'll just point out that
if there were One supplement that really
seems to move the needle in terms of egg
quality which is a morphological but
also a meaningful physiological metric
or and sperm quality which is going to
be shape motility you don't want what
are called Dead sperm they're always
going to be some in a sample because of
the age of the sperm Etc and the way the
spermatogenes the cycle go but you want
forwardly motile sperm the other ones
are called twitchers so you know they
just Twitch in place
they can actually take twitchers and
force them into the egg during IVF
something called ixy but
in general the greater number of forward
motile sperm I'm swimming them towards
you yeah yeah I'm actually swimming them
an angle away from Tim so forward on our
first person podcast day exactly can be
greatly increased by supplementation
with L-Carnitine so egg health and sperm
Health greatly enhanced by L-Carnitine
pretty remarkable results there
injectable L-Carnitine of about one mil
one Mig per day okay that has to be
prescribed by a doctor and that's I am
that's intramuscular yeah or oral
capsules are available over the counter
then you have to get up to four or five
grams per day wow and that could
increase tmao and some other markers
that aren't great for cardiovascular
health because of the way it's processed
by the gut but you can offset that by
taking 600 milligrams of garlic because
of the allicin and garlic okay smoking
cigarettes vaping cigarettes really good
for sperm terrible for sperm terrible
for eggs smoking cannabis vaping
cannabis also terrible eggs and sperm
people don't like to hear that 15 of
women I can't believe the statistic but
I've seen it over and over and to check
my eyes but 15
ingest cannabis at some point during
pregnancy 15 probably not a good idea
now a lot of people say oh I smoke weed
every day and got my wife pregnant
you never know how healthy your children
would have been you never you just never
know I'm not saying your children are
unhealthy but you never are also going
to be there will always be edge cases
who are like I smoke crack every week
and never slept for 14 days straight my
kids are great and you're like okay just
because you happen to be the one mutant
right right right yeah if you want to
optimize for who can thread that needle
exactly it doesn't mean you're a good
model exactly so L-Carnitine can really
help avoid smoking anything
you know the issue of tinctures and
Edibles is a different subject
altogether
I think the big wow
for me was something again I'm just
gonna
tip my hat to you which is that in 2015
I taught a class at I was then a
professor at UC San Diego on neural
circuits and health and disease and I
decided to do a lecture on whether or
not cell phones inhibit sperm health and
or testosterone level
the data were very mixed frankly there
were essentially two good studies in
rats each of them taking a standard
smartphone putting it under a rat's cage
and then looking at some metrics related
to testicular Health sperm Health Etc
one showed increases in testosterone the
other show decreases so it was kind of a
disappointing situation so I would
present both
now there is an extensive meta-analysis
I can send you this for the for the show
notes if you like an extensive
meta-analysis of dozens of studies I'll
add it to the next reprint of the for
our body and it very convincingly shows
that keeping the cell phone in one's
pocket so this isn't putting it to your
head this isn't putting it on the desk
in front of you but keeping it on and in
one's pocket
and it does not matter if it's on Wi-Fi
or you're using seller
decreases sperm quality which means
forward motility number of healthy sperm
per ejaculate Etc even ejaculate volume
to some extent and lowers testosterone
overall which is perhaps not surprising
giving the known heat effects of the
phone so even though it doesn't feel hot
to the touch there are heat effects
sperm don't like heat in fact the most
promising male contraceptive that's out
there that's not a condom is a it's like
a cuff that goes around the vast
deferens which is the portal from the
testes to the urethra that allows the
ejaculate to leave the body that heats
that right I mean asano will it's not a
great form of contraception because it's
not sure proof but it will reduce your
total number of motels born by 75 or so
when I go in the Sonic is five percent
when I do hope to concede children
somewhere so I wear shorts into the
sauna and I actually put a a cold pack
at my groin yeah while I'm in there it's
actually when the sun is really hot it's
also it makes it a little less
unpleasant it's a little painful but you
definitely don't want to do that on bare
skin I'm chuckling too but
heat is part of the problem with the
cell phone but it turns out yes and here
people are gonna think I'm a crazy
person but they might think that already
the emfs that business is real yeah now
is it so real that it's giving us
gliomas unclear I'm not going to go
there the data aren't in but it is very
clear that the radiation from phones the
EMS and the heat are combining to reduce
sperm quality motility and overall
testosterone so it's a simple thing turn
off your phone completely
or even better just don't put it in your
front pocket if you have to put in a
pocket but in your back pocket if you
even better would be to put it in a
shoulder pocket or a backpack
and I also I'm a weirdo perhaps but I
don't like keeping the phone to the my
head too long but that's also because I
don't like holding the end of my head
for too long we don't know very much
about the effects of EMS and heat
effects on the different tissues of the
body but we now know a lot about the
effects of heat and emfs on sperm
quality and it's not a good picture for
the sperm where does airplane mode
fit into this equation if at all in
terms of between on and off I mean does
it
prevent or mitigate some of the effects
it seems to yeah it seems to here's
what's really scary about this
meta-analysis their conclusion is that
the total amount of time spent with the
phone in the pocket is not a strong
determinant that it's it's not all or
none but that the threshold Beyond which
you start seeing these damaging effects
is pretty low so you know again here
we're talking about a don't not a do and
so it's pretty straightforward you know
don't keep the phone in your front
pocket if you're concerned with sperm
health and testosterone production now
why is sperm health and testosterone
production so correlated and you say
well duh it's because you know
testosterone and sperm but if you're not
interested in conceiving children you
might not think this is an issue but
remember that the two types of cells
those lighting cells and the sertoli
cells of the of the testes combine
testosterone in the Androgen binding
protein to give rise to sperm so anytime
you're seeing a reduction in sperm you
are definitely seeing that as a
reflection of reduction in Androgen
binding protein which means whatever
testosterone you have around is also not
having the effect on that local organ
that it should in other words the testes
and the ovaries are very interesting
organs because they secrete hormones
into the body to go have effects but
they also have effects on themselves and
it's self-amplify yeah and so this just
seems like such a straightforward one to
me and you said this back in when was
the four hour body published came out in
2010 yeah yeah and I remember you and
poliquin and a few other people saying
like don't keep the phone in your pocket
and I remember lecturing to about 400
students about this and I would say
about half just you know
by my read about half of the the guys in
the class took the phone out of their
pocket when they heard this
I think young people who aren't thinking
about having children at all right now
are absolutely the ones that should be
most concerned yeah yeah it is true you
can as they told us in high school it
just takes one sperm but you know just
takes one sperm but in order to get that
one sperm to the egg in Vivo you know
not IVF but it's called natural
conception
there's a lot of territory that needs to
be covered there's a lot of chemical
environments that need to be dealt with
you want the healthiest sperm
so I would say also having gone through
this process with an X to create embryos
even though you can say it only takes
one sperm in IVF as well you want to
Stack the odds in your favor which means
you need good morphology good motility
and you need a good count
of non-crippled sperm yeah sperm
analysis can be a humbling thing because
you know no matter what no one's getting
100 motile forward limo tile everyone
males and females learn a lot about
their biology what they're doing well
what they're doing less well when going
down that pathway of IVF I think I think
for women one of the big surprises is
that it doesn't take much ingestion of
alcohol to diminish egg quality you know
Beyond two or three drinks per week per
week
you really start to see reductions in
equality that are probably indirect
through effects on diminished sleep
and changes in stress hormones and so
you know again some people will be more
resilient to this than others people
always like to make jokes about how
alcohol facilitates the conception
process you know Etc you know I think
that in general you know if women are
having very regular Cycles whether or
not they're 28 days long or 35 days long
is less important perhaps and maybe
fairly regular women in general tend to
know more about their bodies and because
they cycle than than men but I if I
could go back in time to my 30s I sure
sure would have Bank sperm then yeah and
you know I feel good about where I've
gotten my parameters but it's really
interesting as you learn this you just
realize that
freezing sperm freezing eggs is a great
idea and freezing embryos makes sense if
you have the appropriate pairing or
situation right yeah and that life gets
so much easier for those wishing to
conceive when you have healthy embryos
Frozen in the bank yeah anyway for those
challenged in that area it also becomes
this like incredibly expensive
emotionally and financially expensive
battle Yeah I will I will say much to my
surprise
that this is I mean within the last year
I suppose
prior to the breakup of course but going
through the IVF or at least embryo
creation process
my sperm quality because I I have banked
starting probably I unfortunately not as
reliably as I would have liked but
probably starting around
2010 or 2012. oh okay quite a while ago
banking sperm sadly there was actually a
technical issue at this particular
location in San Francisco because
they're bought by some larger
conglomerate and I think a lot of the
samples were lost but the point I was
going to make is that
after trying to do a deep dive taking
copious massive L-Carnitine
adding in a few other things like Maca
and a handful of of other basics
my sperm quality is actually better
seemingly better now than it was 10
years ago it was just shocking yeah I
mean it's again if one is doing the
right things yeah I do think that we can
perform physically
probably in the domain of sexual health
too I think that's it that's a
misconception that you know like you
know men peek in their 80s 1880s
at 18 you know I've looked at
testosterone levels as a function of age
in that there's a wonderful book on this
on behavioral endocrinology
and you know there are some and in their
70s who maintain testosterone levels of
similar to men in their 20s and 30s
highly individual depends a ton on how
much people are moving how much sunlight
they're getting how little alcohol and
nicotine smoking nicotine not nicotine
the substance but they're bringing into
their system exposure to environmental
toxins these kinds of things and we
always think of bpas and receipts they
are a problem
handling receipts not good printed
receipts but wait a second hold on but
that's the major source of bpas no [__]
yeah no idea so BPA is always thinking I
like cans bottles this that and the
other thing receipts receipts why the
hell are there so many btas and receipts
yeah Shayna Swann who's done a lot of
the critical work on phthalates and
they're okay influence on your general
distance which is a marker of prenatal
Androgen and gets smaller the generals
and the anus are closer together in
females than in males of of all species
including humans phthalate exposure bpas
in particular is progressively
decreasing eurogenital distance in in
males penis size
in a somewhat contradictory way there's
a study that just came out in of
Stanford from Michael eisenberg's lab
he's a urologist an endocrinologist
we showed that actually a flaccid here
it is again flaccid oh no erect penis
lengths have gone up 26 in the last 30
years but testosterone and sperm counts
are going down so I you know there's a
really interesting study of tens of
thousands of of men yeah I don't I
haven't read the method section how do
they explain that because it makes
though
kind of
superficial sense to me because like if
you're swimmers and your testosterone
are just taking a nosedive you need to
get closer to the goal closer to the
cervix yeah those data are a little hard
to explain but they're they're very
robust data that study was just
published wait a second so the balls are
getting closer to the ass but the the
schlongs are getting longer not to get
too technically no well that's I think
people understand that like Euro General
distance is not a is not a great term
for most people to digest or think about
but you we think about bpas so receipts
yeah probably more than Plastics and
things that sort but also if you look at
the most the people who get the greatest
exposure to these phthalates and that
are impairing their endocrine system the
most in males and females it's going to
be in rural areas because of pesticides
yeah pesticides so we think oh people
living in cities bus exhaust drinking
you know at Red Bull sugar-free Red Bull
from the bodegas in New York City you
know no you're talking about rural areas
of the country and Air born pesticides
Airborne yeah Airborne so I thought I
was I immediately went to to groundwater
dust dropping and this this kind of
thing yeah I was over in Copenhagen to
give a talk last year I was totally
whiffed that I would have gone Urban I
would have thought contaminants me too
and Shayna Swan she's been the one you
know really focusing on this when no one
else really thought much of it and was
thinking oh that's crazy conspiracy
stuff and no there's a real data funded
by the NIH
so I think that you know avoiding
Plastics and things like that sure but I
think handling of receipts especially
because they serious endocrine
disruptors and avoiding pesticides and
then you know alcohol again not trying
to you know rain on a based party here
but past two drinks a week you know is
when you start seeing some negative
health effects and males and females I
did a long episode on this by the way I
drank the occasional drink everyone so I
like white tequila the numbers two most
shared podcasts in the world in 2022. I
did not expect that what alcohol does to
your body brain and health I did not
expect it to have that kind of traction
There's No Agenda there I think a lot of
people think that I'm an AAA or
something I have deep respect for that
Community but no I've never had a
problem with alcohol or drugs it's never
been my thing is that there was no
agenda whatsoever I think that alcohol
is a toxin you know essentially making
toxin for your cells that's part of it's
the way it creates its effects look it
can be enjoyed I also think that if
people are going to drink more than two
drinks per week they want to pay more
attention to the other things that we
talked about at the beginning nutrient
sunlight exercise sleep Etc I'm not
trying to say what people should or
shouldn't do they should just know what
they're doing yeah and talking about how
the preceding 24 hours leads to the
current 24 hours which leads to the next
24 hours A friend of mine I won't give
him credit because he probably doesn't
want it but he's he was quoting someone
else so it doesn't really matter but he
said alcohol is borrowing happiness from
tomorrow oh yeah and I was like yeah
that's a good way to put it yeah and
I've never tried cocaine but from what I
hear cocaine is borrowing happiness from
10 minutes from now I spoke to a guy
recently who's a who is a former cocaine
addict and I said what does it feel like
and he said let me just explain it this
way by the way this is not a direct
quote I'm I'm quoting somebody else he
said that the first time he did cocaine
his experience was one of wow that was
terrible and when can I get more oh God
so that the stall to the experience
I know exists the double system drops
below Baseline I'm too afraid to try
cocaine and especially nowadays with the
fentanyl that's laced in oh yeah so many
street drugs I know two people they were
at a bachelor party in Mexico
otherwise very responsible folks but
they decide to do it a lot of people do
at such parties and decide to do cocaine
they each did one line not a copious
amount these were not cocaine users
both of them immediately collapsed on
the floor one died and one ended up in a
coma for a period of time Fentanyl
my best friend growing up
also was given unbeknownst to him
fentanyl died went fell asleep didn't
wake up so be very careful out there
folks fentanyl is no joke and there are
other things as well but many many many
many many many drugs are
cut with fentanyl including those that
at face value would think make no sense
like Ambien yeah yeah yeah yeah so or
cocaine I mean why why they would cut
Fentanyl which is essentially a sedative
yeah into a stimulant like okay makes no
sense to me but and yet yeah that's
what's happening so be careful out there
folks so to move from cocaine to maybe a
a lesser villain I want to revisit
cannabis for just a second so cannabis
in I'm curious to know because I I have
experienced
incredible
well let's see I'm there may be
trade-offs but benefits with respect to
Onset insomnia from low dose
edible
I could say cannabis but in this case
you know we're talking about in legal
settings where state governments allow
this say 2.5 milligrams of THC
with CBD it just takes too high I mean I
would have to consume just kind of a
mountain of it for it to for it to
subjectively help with that what are the
trade-offs if any with dosages in that
range if you're aware yeah it depends on
who you are so I did an episode on
cannabis I also had on our mutual friend
Nolan Williams who's a one of these
freaks of nature he's a triple board
certified psychiatrist neurologist
neurologist at Stanford underachiever
real underachiever doing a lot on
combination of psychedelics with
transcranial magnetic stimulation talked
about cannabis and ideas solo episode on
cannabis which means basically all I did
was think about read about and talk to
people about cannabis for months on end
here's a story with cannabis it's as you
pointed out it's going to be the ratio
of THC to CBD that's important and for
the real aficionados out there and boy
are they out there because they let me
know they are there's also the terpenes
they're going to be the lemon-like
terpenes and the other kinds of terpenes
and chemicals in these means that are
also going to matter and then also it's
going to be smoking vaping
edible or tincture those are gonna be
the
so here's the deal smoking or vaping
anything is bad nicotine or cannabis or
worse for you than edible or tincture
let's just move that off to the side
high THC concentration cannabis of which
now there is almost pure THC cannabis
available
is dangerous for the following reason
and there I just pissed off some people
but first of all it does have
therapeutic applications for glaucoma
pain management maybe even some mental
health facts ability to help people
certain people focus at low dose
but for
in particular young males in their teens
early teens and 20s who take high THC
containing cannabis there is a much
greater like 4X increase in probability
of psychotic episodes later that don't
ever reverse in fact when I spoke to the
leading researcher on this up in Canada
she told me that the probability that
a lot of what we see is kind of Street
homelessness now what people appear to
be schizophrenic was likely triggered by
high-dose cannabis use now I'm not
trying to return us to the 1960s and
talk about Devil's weed and this kind of
thing it is clear that cannabis has
therapeutic benefits but very high
potency THC cannabis can be a problem at
the dosage you describe 2.5 milligrams
very unlikely to be a problem now
psychologically psychologically and I
mean I could be on 2.5 I'm not but I
could be on 2.5 right now and it would
be it would not be some perceptible dose
it's kind of like micro dose I would
feel it but it would not be externally
obvious now the pure CBD cannabis is
interesting too so-called Charlotte's
Web I think is what's called mainly
available in Colorado I'm told
is a powerful
anti-epileptic in fact parents of
epileptic kids moved to Colorado just so
they can get Charlotte's Web CBD
cannabis in my mind that should be
available legally everywhere given that
is essentially no psychoactive effects
yeah there are a few perhaps but so it's
really the the percentage of THC
relatives a CBD that's important the age
of the user whether or not there's a
predisposition of psychosis you know we
might as well be talking about
psychedelics right might as well you're
talking about psyched dogs and I want to
just pause for a second to say
a few things number one I don't
categorize MDMA as a psychedelic we may
get to that but just for a number of
semantic and phenomenological like a
fancy reasons I don't classify that as a
psychedelic and I would actually
categorize high THC content cannabis as
a strong potential psychedelic and it
has become I would just say the standard
the Baseline of strength has become such
a multiple of what anyone might have
been used to in say the 90s it is almost
beyond belief and I do know of one
direct example
this is the brother of an acquaintance
who had exactly the experience you're
describing which is
chronic short-term but chronic use of
very high TC concentration cannabis and
I should say In fairness that classical
psychedelics can also
spedite the onset of schizophrenic
symptoms and those who would genetically
be predisposed so it's it's not limited
to THC but it is I think under
respected and
overused with the assumption that it's
just cannabis and that's I think that's
a mistake it's a very they can be so
powerfully psychoactive yeah it's
interesting how the the proponents of
cannabis which there are a lot of smart
people in cannabis medicine including a
lot of MDS
always say it's not as bad as alcohol
which to me is just a ridiculous
argument I mean just say that something
is not as bad as alcohol implies that
you know you have to choose one or the
other
I think that cannabis has been very
beneficial for a number of adults who
are through the so-called critical
period of brain plasticity so older than
they need some way to quote unquote take
the edge off in the evening they'll do
an edible on the weekend this kind of
thing that is not what we're talking
about in terms of psychosis we're
talking about kids 12 13 14 taking a you
know like a bong rip or smoking a joint
or vaping a super high potency THC
containing
cannabis and just being high out of
their gourd and feeling like it was a
really good time doing that two or three
times and then and I seen this over and
over again their parents reach out to me
often in fact
for whatever reason and then you hear
about this person being 17 18 there's a
failure to launch component they're a
motivated they're claiming ADHD they're
busy A Stoner who relies on cannabis to
relieve anxiety and
hasn't done much else in the last five
years and or certainly has not managed
to keep up with the mean and you know
and here I'm sympathetic by the way this
is listening to somebody who barely
finished high school we covered that in
the last podcast so you know for other
reasons
but I do worry a lot about these super
high potency compounds I worry about
super high potency anything I mean I
worry about in the realm of of hormone
augmentation we're talking fedojia
tongar Ali not Diana ball you know in
the realm of of augmenting mood and
focus we're comparing very high potency
THC containing cannabis taken in a youth
to
300 milligrams of alpha GPC this is
night and day right it's chemical
augmentation of a completely different
Beast so I think that it's clear that no
cannabis is going to be better for most
people than any cannabis is occasional
use for an adult going to be a problem
probably not yeah probably not I will
we'll also say add to that a few things
number one
I am deeply interested in the
therapeutic applications of cannabis and
all of its constituent Parts I think it
is uh
very undervalued
plant from that perspective and I think
it is is severely underestimated in
terms of potency
just the standard available
particularly in in places where you can
kind of get the baker's dozen
of any number of strains made of
Colorado Etc it's
to believe that you are using something
of almost no risk as compared to
psychedelics
if it's if it contains a lot of THC is a
mistake
so I would just say
consider it on par with some of these
very strong psychedelics and
just be informed and be cautious about
your use I I do think
that there are probably some really
significant applications to
Sleep disorders and I will add just for
people listening I have also tried
CBN specifically which has been
recommended to me for sleep and have not
found it as effective it probably
depends on the specific variety of sleep
disorder but for onset insomnia that is
a product predominantly not of Spike
glucose or I guess cortisol and or then
glucose levels but rather rumination
THC seems to be one of the magic keys in
very low doses but
let's segue from that
two psychedelics so how has your
thinking
any observations commentary
beliefs around psychedelics
changed of less
few years my beliefs and stance and also
what I'm willing to say has completely
changed in the last 24 months
this last week Stanford magazine which
is a magazine of the Stanford Alumni
Association goes out to many more people
than just to attended Stanford
put out an issue of this it's a very
nice bound magazine of the kind that you
would you know take the dentist's office
or you know
on the cover and inside there's a
feature article about psychedelics I
could not believe it at first but it is
essentially a guide to psychedelics it's
not telling you how to do them but it
explains what is ketamine now here
they're broadly defining psychedelics
okay so the classic psychedelics right
psilocybin musculine LLC are included
there chemical structures how they're
used the history clinical trials
happening now known benefits
considerations and risks
for all of those drugs plus ketamine
plus MDMA I was just shocked a
positively shocked because three years
ago five years ago certainly ten years
ago a conversation like this would have
been the conversation that would have
ended my career yes as a university
professor
my understanding is that thanks to the
incredible work of the group with maps
and a number of specific Laboratories
Matthew Johnson's laboratory Robin
Carhart Harris's laboratory role in
Griffith's laboratory and thanks to the
philanthropy organized by you and others
truly and also thanks to the public
education efforts of people like Michael
pollen for sure we are moving very
quickly towards legalization of MDMA as
administered by
either psychiatrist and or licensed
clinical psychologists in the U.S
psilocybin probably a longer road but
I'm told that we'll get there quote
unquote
why am I framing it this way well I'll
just be very direct in high school I
took LSD recreationally several times
had not good experiences the experiences
were far too long 11 15 hours I might
have spent my senior prom in an elevator
you know it may or may not you know can
I confirm or deny my junior prom my
senior prom was a different story and
I'm not recommending people do this I
actually strongly regret doing that at a
time when my brain was plastic I did not
know what I was doing I didn't know the
sourcing
it was a terrible idea terrible idea
even riskier now yeah and keep in mind
folks I was not a star student far from
it it took a lot of years to get my my
act together talked about this before in
Tim's podcast Richard Schultz podcast
and others so you know that certainly
did not help and I don't recommend it I
tried psilocybin recreationally a few
times
didn't get much out of it as an adult
I'm not shy about the fact that I did
two and now three of the Maps
appropriate
physician guided sessions for trauma
using MDMA I've found it immensely
beneficial I'm happy to talk about how
each one of those sessions was different
again this is with a physician as part
of a
study so
what I know now is completely different
than what I knew two years ago which is
not just based on the legality but in
discussions with Nolan Williams this
incredibly impressive colleague of mine
and friend of yours and colleague of
yours really
that the safety profiles on things like
MDMA are actually quite High I was
taught that MDMA was neurotoxic why was
I taught that well there's paper
published in Science magazine
looking at toxicity of MDMA
observing neurotoxic effects turns out
what were they looking at
methamphetamine oops retraction
retraction except that never made the
major headlines okay so then you look at
the data on psilocyb and here I'm just
going to hit the high points because
it's not my work it's the work of
Matthew Johnson and of Robin carnart
Harris at UCSF
intractable depression people who are
suicidally depressed nothing else Works
talk therapy doesn't work
antidepressants don't work TMS doesn't
work
do two high dose so it's 25 milligrams
of psilocybin that has to be translated
for grams of mushrooms but it's roughly
like the 25 to 30 milligram of
psilocybin synthetic psilocybin B
equivalent let's just say a Terence
McKenna heroic dose of five grams I mean
you're getting enough for escape
velocity okay yeah in upwards of 60
maybe 70 percent of these patients that
take that are getting substantial and
ongoing relief that's an amazing result
so much so that the big Pharma has moved
in and is trying to create
non-psychedelic psychedelics to extract
the benefits of these drugs that don't
induce hallucinations instead of raising
interesting questions about whether or
not the experience under psychedelics is
really the trigger for the
antidepressant effect whether or not
it's the inside or not that's a whole
ball of wax and really I'm not qualified
to parse that that's really the domain
of Robin and
and the Psychonauts that's an
interesting set of issues so my stance
nowadays is
there is a compound out there that seems
to have very high safety profiles very
very high certainly for psilocybin that
under the appropriate guidance and
supervision during and after in the
so-called integration phase one or two
dosages of this stuff yes takes people
through a phase of anxiety than a phase
of deep introspection this is also I
learned essential there are two
components I learned are essential that
were surprising to me one you have to be
in the eye mask observing things in your
external environment the whole time
seems to bypass some of the
introspective slash antidepressant
effects later that's interesting to me
it's not just about what you see what
you hear out there it's really about
going inward this kind of trust let go
yeah it's also important to standardize
for trials right you can't have people
looking at all sorts of different stuff
somebody's watching Finding Nemo and
another one's watching Jaws or right
exactly and then the other thing was I
learned from Robin recently is that
music seems to be a key component
now they've never teased out music no
music but having music that starts as he
described it in the distance you know
drums and pacing or something
approaching music
then instrumentals which raise people's
emotional state while they're in the eye
mask and then some transition period out
seems to be a critical component of all
this and guiding some of the kind of
funneling towards deep emotional
introspection
I find this incredibly interesting and
again I would have not felt safe talking
about this keep in mind a year ago two
years ago keep in mind that
in the late 60s early 70s there were
professors at Harvard and Stanford
mainly that were fired or at least asked
to leave for having discussions like
this yeah and now Stanford magazine
itself is printing this and this is also
I'll use this as an opportunity to say
this because it's really about the
listeners you know our podcast
Urban Lab podcast is free on all the
channels but we do have a premium
channel I'm not trying to solicit it
here but the premium channel is designed
to we do amas and things of that sort
transcripts are available to those folks
to raise revenue for research dollars
for exciting work and we have a donor
that's very been very generous to do a
match for that money and we're giving
money only to studies working on humans
not animal studies and two of the major
errors that we're supporting are the
sorts of work that Nolan's lab is doing
and Nolan in particular
to combine transcranial magnetic
stimulation with psychedelics that's
great I didn't know that about about the
premium option yeah that's really what
the premium channel is designed for yeah
that's great again I'm going to say the
same people are going to think that I'm
just here you know kissing up to Tim but
I'm doing that over text all the time
anyway because this is yet another
example where you got into science
philanthropy early
you reach out to your connects you are
very vocal about what you felt was
powerful and it worked for you and what
you've been observing and I am
absolutely clear I've said this on
Twitter I'll say it again when we look
back in five years 10 years 100 years
there's going to be a small subset of
individuals For Whom the transition of
psychedelics from these like Niche
communities hippie communities carpet
Flyers everything from Devil's weed you
know craziness to True truly effective
compounds for treating psychiatric
illness
you're going to be on that list Roland's
gonna be on that list Matthew is going
to be on that list pollen's going to be
on that list Robin's gonna be on that
list for sure also you know and Nolan I
think is going to be on that list
there's gonna be a small subset of
people that we're gonna go listen
research takes money it takes focus it
takes a bravery and it also takes the
willingness to like take something that
has been looked at as just like drugs
you know and turn it into something
that's therapeutically meaningful so
yeah we're just all I'm trying to do is
you know raise some dollars through the
premium channel that's what we've been
doing to pump into research studies and
so what I mean you can tell I'm super
excited by all this what I see happening
now is that soon MDMA
for trauma is going to be available to
the countless numbers of people out
there that have trauma and I don't mean
just take MDMA and have a great time I'm
I mean people developing empathy for
themselves I mean people really working
through the barbed wire stuff of their
past much of which they had no control
over that sets this transgenerational
thing that's been going on for so long I
mean really you know you've used the
language you know been the Arca history
like
these compounds are going to bend the
Arca history in the right direction and
if people out there are listening and
saying okay well this is like
recreational stuff and it's very
precarious I do not know a single major
let's just call them what they are CEO
or company founder we're talking about
people with kind of billionaire level
that are hyper creative hyper creative
and Hyper functional in their life we're
not talking about Mystic creatives we're
talking about people who I don't want
named names but every single one of them
already knows this is true because
they've all done this stuff already and
I was kind of late to the train because
I had such a terrible experience in my
high school years and saw so many
friends dead suicide drug addicts in
jail like wrecked their lives I had so
many challenges taking myself from
essentially a loser with nowhere to go
to you know a trajectory within Academia
and taking good care of my body that I
was like no drugs no drugs I don't even
put psyched dogs in the category of
drugs and here I'm lumping MDMA and
they're provided it's done with a
licensed physician or clinician who can
guide this stuff it's been immensely
beneficial for me what were your
different sessions like
to the extent that you're willing to
share the first one I can just summarize
by saying was extremely somatic waves of
a lot of shaking
at the beginning of the session I walked
in feeling like I could think and feel
things from the neck up I could think
and feel things not think but I could
feel things from the waist down but that
my body wasn't integrated as a system I
left that session feeling completely
comfortable in my body as a whole system
and Far More in tune with my emotions
far more comfortable being having
emotions far less afraid of what
emotions might do to me whether or not
they were a vote from inside or from
outside I felt as a consequence I felt
much braver in the world
and I felt a kind of a healthy adaptive
level of fearlessness because I felt
like nothing can hijack my internal
emotions and even if they do I'll be
okay
and that was a significant thing the
second session very different I expected
everything as I did in the first never
works that way was one of deep deep
acceptance around
resents forgiveness of resents that I
had for people that I felt had neglected
me or just or did not do what they
needed to do or that I felt a lot of and
you might be able to sense a little bit
of emotion here it's it's hard because I
can still sense the ways in which
thoughts about that are painful but
mostly because it's it seems so
senseless to me now yeah and yet I have
truly zero resent like I I look for it
often to just check myself to it no
resent like complete forgiveness which
has given me tremendous relief and then
the third session was interesting
the recession was a higher dose I'd
never taken the booster the maps booster
took the booster and
I lay completely still for about eight
hours and it was very introspective and
I think I left that session and I still
maintained from all the everything I've
described by the way I feel I've
maintained years later now
the third session which was more recent
I felt I finally understood
and kind of sealed up what I can only
describe as like boundaries like that
other people can have emotions and
experiences that are truly separate from
me I tend to be pretty affiliative I
think that came out of an early
especially with friends you know and in
relationships that came out of an early
need to
feel some sense of family where I didn't
feel that as much as I would have liked
from my biological family
and there have been times when I've been
unable to really
keep in touch with kind of how my my
life and is distinct from and my
emotions are distinct from other people
a little bit too much of empathic
blurring sometimes and I felt like that
was just sealed right up
and mind you each time I went into these
sessions I was afraid of all the
standard things losing my mind having a
heart attack now granted if you have
heart issues tell your physician you
don't want to do MDMA it is an
amphetamine in there but I was afraid of
all the standard stuff each time I felt
like the window on introspection and
plasticity lasted much longer weeks
longer and
each time I just felt like I got better
and better at self-care which in my mind
was always a very selfish thing yeah I
always thought self-care is selfish you
know even working out I used to hide
working out when I go to conferences
because I thought like no academic like
goes to the gym and lifts weights and I
really like doing that but I realized
how much stronger I was mentally when I
was taking care of my physical body I
think that things have changed now but
so the third session was very meaningful
for me because I felt like it kind of
sealed something up yeah where I go okay
like I'm I'm good like things can happen
around me and I'm not gonna get pulled
into it
in a way that compromises my well-being
yeah of course I still have a lot in
there and work to do and Robin cardard
Harris
said to me recently he said well you
know psilocybin is really the honest
psychedelic because there you don't have
the empathogen that's woven into the
MDMA so you're really going to see
whatever Darkness still exists within
you and I thought oh goodness but you
know now I am spoken as a true
psilocybin researcher you know so so
they hear they you know you hear about
people like is it calling to you I'm
afraid to do psilocybin for that reason
I definitely worked hard to kind of
suppress some of the dark clouds in my
head
and yeah but the fact that I'm still a
bit afraid for them is probably the
reason why I should do it
oh well it also I think means you're
coming to it from an intellectually
honest place if if someone has
absolutely no concerns or misgivings
about extremely powerful psychedelics
I mean you are playing with
psychological nuclear power so yeah
revealing the unconscious I mean I
didn't even know what psychedelic meant
but it I mean Robin taught me it means
revealing the unconsciousness yeah mind
manifesting yeah and I still do you know
extensive amounts of psychotherapy and
psychoan Analysis I look at that as just
like going to the gym yeah I'm fortunate
that my insurance can help pay for that
and I'm able to pay for it so I
understand not everybody can but I I
still feel that
yeah if we don't actually take the time
to figure out what's going on in our
head so how can we really trust that
we're on the best path yeah or just
representing
reality to our benefit in a sense right
because we're we're perceiving but also
constructing reality and sometimes
if you think your glasses are scratched
or smeared or foggy or whatever you need
to take them off and look at them there
are a few ways to do that with your own
psyche there are very few tools that
allow you to do that and I would
recommend for folks if they are
interested in and thank you for being so
forthcoming with describing your
experiences
getting a good overview of how
MDMA specifically can help with say
complex PTSD and why it has become such
a focal point for many many researchers
and practitioners I do recommend the
Netflix how to change your mind
miniseries that pollen was involved with
based on the book of the same name and
specifically the the MDMA episode I
thought was was spectacularly well done
I need to see that still it's very well
done and includes a lot of case studies
and interviews with research subjects
and there's also documentary that I
helped bring to well outside of Israel
called trip of compassion this was
probably four or five years ago which
contains session footage as well
construction value is going to be a bit
lower than Netflix so you might want to
try that first but their number of
forthcoming books coming that'll be that
will be focused on these topics a lot of
good stuff happening in terms of
Investigation there are risks there are
very non-trivial risks and
that is
you know part of the reason why the the
fundamental research is important which
is why people like
I have to mention Roland because he was
my Gateway into so much of this role in
Griffiths and
Robin and Nolan and others are are doing
very very important work because there's
the commercialization
there's the development of derivatives
and perhaps non-psychedelic options and
I think that they hold promise in
certain conditions like cluster
headaches for instance
however
I do firmlies fall into the camp that
believes there are these mechanistic
receptor level effects and many other
physiological measurable effects that
exert or impart some of the benefits
that we document in Trials but I am
firmly in the camp that the content
matters
deeply yeah it's it's interesting you
know Rob and I and Nolan and I also
discussed things like Ebola ibogaine 22
hour long psychedelic Journey no
hallucinations with eyes open close the
eyes see
drop into very vivid imagery of previous
experiences that doesn't interest me so
much it seems a little bit much it's
going to be hard also to do clinical
studies on that as Robin point out one
of the reasons why most of the trials
are being done with psilocybin or MDMA
is because the sessions are four to six
hours without Aftercare LSD triple
double or triple that eight to twelve
generally yeah and and of course we
should point out that street MDMA could
very well be and is often laced with
fentanyl so the sourcing here must be
through Maps I think they're the only
ones that actually have the clean
sourcing of MDMA I know people out there
will be like I know a clean Source but
nowadays I think people need to be
exceedingly cautious about fentanyl
because it's deadly you know there's an
organization called dance safe which I
encourage people to check out which
provides kits because I know that you
know you can tell kids abstain no sex no
sex just no sex until you're married
they're gonna have sex anyway so I
recognize people who are listening are
probably going to use drugs
from unclear sourcing or it will be a
game of telephone it'll be from from
five different ten different 12
different 100 different hands to theirs
dance safe has kids I'm not recommending
that you use drugs in that fashion but
people are going to do it anyway there
are kits you can purchase which will
help you to detect some of these
contaminants so at the very least do
that type of due diligence
yeah so you asked how you know how do I
feel about these compounds done in the
clinical setting and how is my stance
change complete 180. complete 180. I'm
super curious I'm super excited and you
know
least of all for me I'm excited about
what my experience it was very positive
all around but I'm most excited for the
you know millions and millions maybe
even billions of people out billions of
people certainly have trauma but the
millions of people who are
impaired in terms of daily mood and
basic functioning because of depression
anxiety I mean that there are psilocybin
trials for fibromyalgia for anorexia
nervosa the most deadly psychiatric
illnesses it's anorexia
of course people with bipolars
schizophrenia these are not good
candidates because of the propensity for
exacerbating psychosis or manic episodes
but you know I think we are heading into
really interesting times and a year or
two ago I would have thought this isn't
going to make it through the shoot
something's gonna happen and the whole
thing's gonna fall apart I think it was
the event that we were both at the
veteran Solutions event on Coronado
Island it's an incredible group that
you're associated with and we have
common friends in from the Special
Operations Community who are doing these
iboga DMT combined sessions out of
country and then working with Nolan
Williams to look at how the brain
changes
and we saw Governor Rick Perry there
yeah well a pretty right-wing guy oh
yeah and then Rick and Rick yeah
who had the the who stood up there and
said in front of a room full of special
operators that he'd been a conscientious
objector during the Vietnam war and I
thought wow if he doesn't get killed in
this room he's going to survive forever
in other words polar extremes
politically standing there talking about
psychedelics and their value for
treatment of intractable depression
trauma
offsetting the certain amount of suicide
risk in many individuals talking about I
think I heard Rick Perry say the words
heart medicine I almost fell out of my
chair yeah I mean this is super exciting
you know the only way to describe it is
the way that
Paul Conte sometimes describes things
like there are certain things for which
there's a lot of work a lot of potential
Hazard but that done properly and he
wasn't referring to psychedelics
particularly but like there's so much
goodness that could come out of this
like the amount of goodness that could
come out of it everyone having access to
Great Medical Care therapy and
potentially psychedelic therapies I mean
just imagine like the magnitude of the
world change like that's the kind of
stuff that gets chills running up my
spine and you just think well gosh but
the scale of that problem is just too
big legally financially but enough has
happened now that at least some of that
in terms of psychedelics could very well
happen and again to clarify what Paul
Conte wasn't talking about psychedelics
he just has this occasionally he'll say
something we're doing a series with him
and and on mental health and
occasionally he'll say something like
about you know certain things are just
goodness you know and I love the sound
of that because it sounds there's
something so wholesome about it but but
so real I mean waking up and feeling
good enough to pursue the basic events
of the day
with some hardship of course from time
to time good enough to you know set a
goal and fail and then try again you
know good enough to like have a rough
run through a relationship or or a hard
family life or lose all your money and
go bankrupt and come back like this is
stuff of real life and I think that
there's so many so-called deaths of
Despair and then they're 10 times more
sort of lives of Despair you know out
there and I think this is the
opportunity for real healing yeah lack
of a better word High leverage very high
leverage I'm excited to see where it
goes and I I would I would tell people
also
don't be shy about following the money
in the sense that there will be every
possible attempt to contort
and change psychedelic therapies to fit
into existing
Healthcare and I do think there's upside
to that right not everyone is going to
be able to afford
whatever the costs may be to
receive bespoke Medical Care with a
session that lasts 18 hours or whatever
it is 12 hours let's just say in the
case of the sort of upper range for some
people with LSD
however if you see a company that's
saying five meodmt is the ticket because
it's the businessman's Psychedelic
therapy because it lasts 15 minutes take
a sniff test or two first and also just
because it's 15 minutes Earth time
doesn't mean you're experience 15
minutes so just be cautious with that
the removal of psychedelic effects also
makes it much more adaptable and plug
and play with
with current Healthcare practitioners
and things can be turned into
maintenance doses so if we look for kids
right so you say if you take like
generic ketamine I'm not going to name
too many names but some of the
sort of slight slight molecular changes
that have been made to create say
maintenance doses with nasal sprays
I I do think that at least for me and I
may be old-fashioned but I do think that
these compounds and relatively few
sessions have the potential to induce
plasticity provide experiences that have
I'm not going to say well in some cases
Curative capability or potential but
extremely high durability right we're
talking on the order of years so
I think people should be skeptical of
companies that aim to create maintenance
drugs from these although that could be
applicable to certain populations that
say
may fit into exclusionary criteria
because they can't take higher doses for
risk of say psychosis but they might be
able to take very very low doses along
the lines of say a microdose which
wouldn't impart the perhaps content
experiences but could have some effects
on serotonin type 2A receptors but
intracellularly which I was just reading
about I would recommend if people want
to keep up to speed with these things
the microdose from UC Berkeley is
fantastic that's sort of a News Bulletin
summary on a weekly basis if you want a
good overview I think how to change your
mind is a great place to start if you
want to know how some psychotherapists
have worked with these things I think an
oldie but a goodie healing journey by
Claudio naranjo I think is excellent
even if you just buy it for the
introduction I think Maps sells that so
a lot of good resources out there
Andrew we've covered a lot of ground we
have and it's so nice to spend time
together we're going to grab some dinner
is there anything that you would like to
add Point people to any closing comments
you'd like to make before we wrap up
no at one point we had thought we might
cover
how to optimize a podcast and there I'm
just going to point people to the great
series that you did I think it was one
or two episodes I did an episode with
Chris Hutchins
because he wanted to ask me a million
questions about podcasting and I said
you know what I get asked this all the
time let's just record a podcast and
then I can point people to the Box
perfect well my whole team listened to
it my whole team listened to it and
talked about it and used it as kind of a
checklist for whether or not we were
doing things right that was about a year
ago and things are going well so I'll
just point people to that episode
hopefully you can link to that episode
because it's really great we thought yes
yes and oops we better be doing that no
I I really just want to extend my
gratitude for the work you've done in
the past I know I've mentioned it over
and overnight I'm sure some listeners
are probably like here he goes again
thank you Tim but I would not be
podcasting we're not for you and Lex
Friedman who gave me the like the final
nudge but yeah and also I've just
gleaned so much valuable Knowledge from
your books and your podcasts and learned
so much from you so again for me it's
like pure delight to be sitting here
having this conversation and feel very
honored and I'm really grateful to you
and your team and
I hope you'll come on the huberman Lab
podcast before long absolutely I need to
I need to need to make a trip to SoCal
thanks for saying all that it really
means a lot and it has been a [__]
blast to watch you just
storm the front man it's really been fun
to see the podcast do as well as it is
done to see that then also lead into
other types of
snowball effects like providing funding
as I just learned for studies vis-a-vis
the the premium option
and
keep it up man I'm I am certainly
learning a lot and taking notes myself
you can see you can see the notes in
front of me it might not be visible on
video but I've been taking notes through
the whole conversation as I always do
when I listen to you talk whether it's
on your podcast or in person so people
can find you hubermanlab.com we will
link to YouTube Instagram Twitter but it
is huberman lab on all these platforms
and I encourage people to subscribe
check it out and
thank you Andrew
and to everybody listening we will have
links to all sorts of things including
that light vest that we'll figure out in
the show notes at tim.blog podcast you
can just search Andrew or huberman
h-u-b-e-r-m-a-n and all things will pop
up so until next time just be a bit
Kinder than is necessary to other people
and yourself and pay attention to those
fundamentals those pillars all good
things come from paying attention to
those checklists and as always thanks
for tuning in